I'm getting emotional that this might be the last time we
hear this!
No!
Moe, moe, boom!
Hello everybody!
Welcome, welcome, howdy, howdy!
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hello!
Hello, konnita!
Hello, hello.
Howdy, howdy, howdy.
All good things come to an end, right?
We'll see.
What if I don't finish today?
Who knows?
We might.
Bring it back one more time.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome back to Deadly Premonition.
Oh, my gosh.
I love this game.
I haven't been able to stop thinking about this game since
the last time.
I'm like, oh, geez, I...
I know we do have lots of side quests we could fill up time
with, right?
Just do nothing but fish.
It's been a pleasure to watch this.
I hope that everybody who has joined us until now has...
And maybe if there is one more, I guess you'll know by the
title, huh?
Later on, but everybody, I hope everybody has enjoyed Deadly
Premonition.
Longer game series like this are always just a...
Especially wackadoo ones like this.
They're always such a treat.
It feels like a kind of bonding between all of us.
It feels like, I don't know, we're going on some grand
adventure together.
I love it.
Hello, Mito and Ibus like you.
Nice to see you on this fine Sunday with the possible last
part of Deadly Premonition.
hope you're feeling better.
Can't wait to see you at the Maid Cafe meet and greet.
Come on, I'm seeing you at the Maid Cafe meet and greet.
Let's go!
I'm very excited for the Maid Cafe meet and greet because
it's a little special than other meet and greets.
So I'm excited.
I'm excited.
Hopefully, I can do more special ones in the future as well.
Series inside jokes.
Exactly!
on 1 million views on unbound and new outfit tomorrow yeah i
can't believe it i can't believe 1 million views it's heavy
heavy heavy pulling in the heavy work it's a shared journey
and sometimes trauma bonding yeah yeah yeah yeah and yes new
outfit tomorrow baby oh my god new album tomorrow I'm like
90% ready
and Spain won oh wait the I was actually looking at updates
I was like the finalist today isn't it like is someone gonna
win and then when I was eating right before stream it said
they were on break or something so I was like oh okay
minutes ago where my impeccable timing of starting stream
right as the World Cup ends when I looked too it was like
maybe I don't know a half hour ago 40 minutes ago nobody had
scored oh it went extra time no wait what a letdown or maybe
it's more exciting I don't know I don't know what people
prefer the good guy squad I saw something I don't know much
about the cup but i did see that i don't know am i gonna get
in trouble for this okay i saw that people were saying that
like they wanted spain to win because i don't know uh
argentina turned into like the villains of of the world cup
i don't know what that means though
yeah hello i hope you feel better today i'm feeling a bit
better thank you so much sorry yesterday I was supposed to
stream balloons but I will move balloons to Tuesday so
Tuesday I'm gonna actually do double streams because I'm
gonna play balloons and I'm gonna take a little break for
food and then I'm gonna do a collab with sloppy sisters and
Matara and Nimi and we're gonna be playing power world power
world power world are you doing okay today I am I am
medicated and
yeah I have a friend named Zach that I made play this game
the daggers he stared at me with every time I quote this
game can fuel me for life she took her meds yeah now chat is
gone actually and I also don't hear Zack in my head anymore
so don't know what that's all about what if we're name our
name is actually Zack and we just made up York nobody call
us us that but we tell everybody call me York it's what
everyone calls me but it's not actually what people call me
they call Mike they call me my real legal name Zack don't
make us disappear!
I'm so excited to see where this game goes, though.
It always surprises me.
Every week, I am surprised by a new thing.
And it's great.
I love it.
I'm gonna miss this game so much if today is the last day
that we're playing.
I was just yorking it all along.
Are you considering a side quest stream of this game Um,
maybe...
Yeah, I'm ready for a wild ending too.
I feel like I would either do side quests today though, or
maybe...
Maybe like a member side quest thing, something, something.
I'm glad I didn't watch a YouTube video about it a while ago
so I can experience it as it goes.
Now I want to watch YouTube videos about it Because I'm
like, what did I miss?
You know?
What else?
What other craziness is happening?
We did like...
What was the one side quest where we got our car washed?
That was something.
Clitamad, welcome back!
Thank you.
Also, I feel like there's so many things I'm missing in that
like...
Um...
I thought...
uh oh wait wait hold on let me finish my thought before i
read you guys um there are so many cards the trading cards
you can get they're like stuck inside little places and i
don't know how to get into them so oh you never got a new
car i've just been stealing cars mattie i hope you're
feeling better spain just won yeah i know i don't know if
vicky told you yet i've i don't think we've been discussing
the world cup But I saw that she was doing a watch-along.
Yes, yes.
Lance, thank you so much for the big...
Akasapa!
Doing dormy stuff right now with coworkers after finishing
the soccer finals.
We'll catch up with the vibe when I can.
Hope you're doing better.
Thank you!
Have fun with your coworkers.
Have fun!
Yeah, I also never unlocked fast travel, right?
She woke up at 3 a.m.
Yeah.
crazy I guess other people would be doing that too though if
like in Japan if Japan made it to the finals I where where
was the finals at like what I guess were they were they LA
or wait New York New Jersey ah New Jersey oh Okay, okay.
America?
New Jersey.
Jersey.
New York.
Call me York.
Always hyped for Gothaminto.
I like being a little goth sometimes, even if it's just
changing my color palette.
People were walking across the highway to get to the
stadium.
No, they were.
were not?
No, they were not.
Glad you're doing okay, Minto.
Yesterday was my birthday!
Prick!
I missed your birthday!
I'm so sorry!
Happy birthday!
I saved you some cake.
Thank you!
I'll be coming over and having it for sure.
A lot of the side quests in this game are on a strict time
limit, so it's kind of worth it if you restart sometime
because there's some you missed completely.
Even if it's a slog.
I see.
Interesting.
Good to know.
I know everyone's minds are on off-kite right now, but I
wanted to thank you and Densetsu for coming to Mochi Expo.
New small concert.
It really means a lot that you all will be there.
Of course.
Thank you, Empirical.
I'm excited for it.
I'm excited for more VTuber conventions to pop up elsewhere
so that everybody doesn't feel like they have to always be
flying to the West Coast.
because I for sure know that pain so I would love and then I
would love also that we can do more concerts and more events
and big things and other places as well so and that's just
the US I hope we can do lots more stuff in other countries
as well welcome back thank you thank you thank you so the
sadness of living in the Midwest.
That's...
What?
But Mochi Expo is literally Chicago.
No?
That's the Midwest.
Is it not?
St. Louis.
Wait.
Missouri.
Wait, what am I thinking of then?
I don't even know where I'm going.
Wait, where's Missouri?
St. Louis is not part of Chicago?
St. Louis is still Midwest.
I was right.
Is that why it's called Missouri?
Sad there.
Geogessor.
I am.
I'm the guesser.
I'm the guesser I have to confess Recently I hear a certain
Zack in my head And let's just say he's not an easy guess In
my brain Have you Present Johnny Silverhand From Cyberpunk
Same fact I've never played Cyberpunk
If you have a Zack in your head you gotta watch out for
women because they'll become interested in him instead of
you it's a native american word missouri oh wow what does it
mean then it's so funny because sometimes you'll like see
like cities that were are like transformed english words but
like it would have been like you know the town of or the
state of misery but it turned into missouri i wish boston
had a vtuber focus convention the east coast needs more
vtuber stuff in general what i have to say about that is if
you feel like you are capable of running one then try
setting it up you know if you are so passionate about it
obviously if You can't, that's one thing.
But it definitely, an event planning is way more difficult
than most people imagine it to be.
I saw you in my dreams.
You ate all the cookies.
I would.
It wasn't a dream.
We need to work convention on my house.
Let's go.
Yeah, Skyline Serenade is coming up.
Skyline Serenade.
during Anime NYC weekend!
I'm excited!
We've been talking about, like, what other things we can do
in New York.
I might be going to my first ever Broadway show.
Crazy!
If I can go.
I really want to go, though.
My first ever!
Are you going to watch cats?
No.
What show?
There's a co- I only know two that are playing And we're
still discussing which one to go see I'll let you guys know
afterwards I'll let you guys know after If I host Aminto
Khan in my backyard Will you attend as the guest of honor?
Yeah!
I would actually I would actually Actually I've always
wanted somebody to invite me to their wedding I will become
officiated Is that what the word Is that the right word?
I will become a monk so that I can marry you.
No, marry you to the other person.
Sorry.
So I can marriage you.
I can...
I messed it up.
I messed up the words.
Sorry, my medicine makes me a little loopy.
Mary you I will marry you to another person I will say now
you may kiss the person I don't know who you're marrying Can
I invite you to my wedding as the bride That's scandalous
You can't wear white to a wedding Unless you're the bride
Can you attend my wedding as the bride
Oh only the bride is allowed to wear a white I can't.
I can't wear it.
Let me...
Let me say marriage.
Minto officiates the first Ibu wedding.
I want to!
Minto's ordained in St. Louis, Chicago.
Chicago.
Cago dog.
Makes an idea for a breakfast cereal.
Freaky loopies.
Can you attend my wedding as the cake?
Is wedding cake good?
I guess it depends on what you get, huh?
I've always wanted to pretend that I was getting married so
I could go taste some samples.
It's all I want.
Just a single slice and I'll be like, that was good.
I'll think about it.
Do you have to prove that you're getting married or will
people just trust you?
Will people trust you that you are getting met?
Because who else would do that maybe?
Do I have to be like here?
How would you prove it?
Like you show that you have a wedding venue and a person to
marry?
I don't know.
Because the samples are free, right?
You sample the wedding and then the wedding cake, and you're
like, oh, yeah, I want this one, or no, I don't want this
one.
You officiate a wedding, you've got to do the prince's pride
voice.
The prince's bride?
You mean marriage?
I don't think they're free.
Oh, no!
What if you go, though, and you hate their style of bacon?
depends on the place you have to pay for the samples in some
cases my plan my plan
it's costco rules right free samples with membership yes
wait we should go to costco and do wedding cake sampling or
just samples actually i got some really good stuff at costco
last time i went because of the samples i was influenced i
was influenced i got this It's really delicious like sesame
dressing.
And it's so good.
And I eat it with carrots.
I would want a wedding tiramisu.
Don't give me ideas.
What?
Oh, tiramisu wedding cake would be the best thing ever.
Invite me?
invite me let me let me let me officiate your marriage I
will marry you to the person today's episode mint commits
fraud for cake what if I make a sob story then maybe the
samples will be free if I'm like if I'm like if I'm like oh
oh I'm so sad.
Then maybe they would give it to me.
Please.
Free wedding cake sample.
I'm nailing it.
Please.
I'm so sad.
I need wedding cake.
wedding cake samples for free.
What if I say I dropped my wallet down the drain?
Actually, I dropped it down the drain, and then Pennywise
said, here you go, kid.
And then he beat me up, stole all my money, cursed me.
I need a free sample.
You should order a wedding cake for Legends.
a new wait i think getting a cake for legends of new would
be so great actually i wonder if i could i'm gonna write
that down that's a wonderful idea cake for legends a new
yeah new minto light novel this marriage fraud is keeps
getting left at the altar but only to score fancy cake
instead of insurance money i would like you to be my
officiant my and my main receptionist would be a maid cafe.
I'm a receptionist?
Never tell Costco you have no money.
Wait, why?
Rinto really wants cake.
I think I do.
Drop your wallet down the drain right before the wedding?
A free cake for sure.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Because you won't buy the stuff they're giving you for free.
So true.
When I was...
When I was last...
At Costco.
One of the guys was giving a free sample.
And some dude walks up to him.
some like old guy and he goes he goes they were like talking
about oh even was the sample oh I remember it was like some
sort of like fruit some sort of fruit sample or something
and the guy is just like Konichiwa may I take the sample and
the guy giving the
the guy giving the sample goes, I'm Vietnamese.
And the other guy goes, thank you guys
have to teach, does anybody know how to say thank you in
Vietnamese so that if I ever run into that guy again?
I can be like...
Same thing happens to me, I'm Chinese.
I'm so sorry.
Come on.
Looking forward to the part of the game you're about to
play.
Well, we're about to play it.
We are.
I don't want to...
I'm so...
I really do want to get into the game.
Come on, Minky, play some fun.
Hacking games.
I have a lore question.
How haunted is the mid-cafe?
Is it just Ibus everywhere?
Or is it Freddy Krueger gonna sit next to me and go?
If the food doesn't kill you, the service will?
I know.
I just like mostly just...
Well, I'm the only, like...
You know, Ibus kind of come and go.
You guys aren't here all the time, you know?
Come on, Vituber!
Oh, but...
But, but we, I don't like, I don't like sharing.
And it's a main cafe.
Like, I'm busy.
I don't have time for other ghosts to be doing their
haunting thing.
I don't, I don't, you know?
Oh, yes, I am.
Are you?
Then go watch my dishes right now, please.
I didn't have time to do it before stream.
Please do that.
the laundry.
I took a shower earlier and I forgot that I had put my
towels in the wash and I had no towel because somebody
didn't put them in the dryer.
It was me.
I hate that.
They're in the dryer now, but they're done.
Yeah, I had to I had to run around I had to streak through
my own cafe hoping that no no curious like urban explorers
walk in they being like today we're at I'm I'm Mikey Mikey
the crikey like urban explorer extraordinaire and today
we're gonna go explore this abandoned maid cafe and then
they see me dripping wet butt naked I would look probably
like I could probably I would probably look like Samara a
little bit maybe that would be good maybe next time if I
maybe next time if I don't have a towel I'll crawl I'll
crawl on the floor to my neck to my towel so that if anybody
comes in they'll be freaked out
Sounds like a smiling friend's bit.
You could violently shake like a doggo.
Oh, that's true.
This is a game like Fatal Frame, but you have to catch the
running ghost looking for their towel.
Not photos though, not photos.
Anyway.
Captain Klein!
Happy birthday!
I'm sorry, you're feeling sick!
No!
But happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Minto walking like Bigfoot searching for a towel.
No, I only walk like Bigfoot when I have to go to the
bathroom.
New Senron Kagura.
When are we getting a new Senron Kagura?
Are they still working on the mobile game?
All right, shall we?
get to the game let's do it let's do it let's do it let's do
it let's do it let's do it let's do it let's do it let's do
it let's do it an intruder breaks into your main cafe are
you going to a ghost wait a poltergeist or prankster maybe
poltergeist you gotta get them out let's see all right
resume episode 4 chapter 21
let's pay Harry another visit and get to the bottom of all
this and that one and that one too all red seeds welcome the
killings 50 years ago There is something about it that you
won't find her and meet those files.
Oh yeah.
The people were attacking and killing each other.
Rampaging as though insane.
Did we learn that last time?
York.
I told you.
That's nothing more than local folklore.
Oh, what does that all mean?
It's called the legend of the new Rainbow Killer.
York.
We found Thomas.
Oh, you found Thomas all right.
Okay.
So it's not bonus footage.
It's still part of the main feature.
exactly who I thought I still think the perp is I still
think the perp is mr.
Stewart Stewart's assistant poor guy I don't even know his
name why is he smiling like that York doesn't really oh god
we're still chasing this dog wait I forgot we ended here I
forgot we ended here whoa sorry to get freaky here this is
the i want to quit the game song what's wrong something's
bothering you oh no it's just i promised to have tea with
with polly i just remember what's that got to do with
anything yep you're right this just isn't the time i know
but it's you know hell she reminds me of my mother who
passed away kason i've been a salesman for a long oh polly
is the lady that owns the hotel right time to talk with my
mother you know say the dog is getting away for me no matter
what happened this was more important so even when she was
sick i put more energy into my work which i regret now and
you know when i heard she died i was trauma dumping i was on
my way home all happy I closed a big deal in New Jersey just
when you want to give something back You got no one to give
it the dog running around in the bag.
That's when I met her Polly I thought heaven had given me
another chance.
Polly's not your mom.
Well, we stay in that hotel whenever I come up here.
Oh, sure the rooms are great But but in all honesty, I go
there because I want to talk with Polly.
Does Polly know all this?
No, no way.
I'd never say anything so embarrassing to her.
She'd think I've got We got some crazy fun on the left side.
Right, let's get going.
Deputy Willie disapproves of any chit-chat.
I'll make it up to Polly some other time, I guess.
Oh my god.
Where'd the dog go?
Oh, there.
We're going after them.
Getting kind of crazy in this town.
We're going after the dog.
Keep running after the dog.
Emily has great stamina.
Keep going after the dog.
Why did you stop?
Why, why did you stop?
Oh, why did you stop?
We gotta keep following the dog.
If Kason has great cardio...
Oh, we're back to being...
Zach, I'm hungry, but I can't do much about that at the
moment.
I'm a hungry!
I'm a great cook.
It's a shame to keep his cooking hidden out here.
Oh, there's a phone over here.
Don't you think so, Zach?
Oh, which reminds me we're hallucinating Emily great cook in
town The fall in love with her would mean that I would need
to love her cooking to what is happening?
Why does God test us so I wonder that coffee she made?
Man, did that pack a punch.
I wish you could have tasted it Zack.
Oh
What I got it What kind of like anti-anxiety?
image is is is york on because the guy has just not a only
chill bones in his body like the guy is so I'm so glad we
took a break from running around to to have that discussion
yeah we're following the dog look at her her posture is
great so Wow!
Such great running posture, okay?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Got that cartoon running posture.
It's only a hunch now, but I don't think Nick killed us.
You're right.
What do you mean?
Me and Diane, we were, you know, pretty close.
Sure, some people might have moral issues about it all, but
I'd like to know.
to think that i knew her pretty well every time we we
finished talking she'd bring up art i'd make a face you know
boring and she'd always say you're so different from nick
he's so much more you finished sounds like something she'd
say nick was one of the few people she could talk to you
know and vice versa for nick i suppose diane also told me
that she was best friends with nick we have nothing at all
to gain by killing her i can't believe that one would try to
the other I just can't yeah we are going through every BGM
still the voices and footsteps I heard that night they were
something else much more violent more more horrifying Wow
voice sounded different too different hard to explain but of
course I couldn't make out what she was saying you told York
all this of course I did what did he say I know that's fine
something like that Yeah, can we get back to the case now or
something?
Let's go then and catch Diane's killer.
Yeah!
I don't know why it always goes to the goofy BGM.
For...
Oh!
Let's go!
Like, it always...
The goofy BGM never fits.
In almost any scenario that we do...
It, like, 90% of the time is ill-fitting to the scenario.
Missing person.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Someone gives it its time.
Oh, I know.
I'm not, it's not a complaint.
Don't get me wrong.
I very much, I love this game too much.
Why do you keep stopping?
Goof and toes.
This is truly...
This BGM should come with a skateboard.
Well, if you like this game.
Zach, about Emily.
Don't you feel almost nostalgic looking at her?
There is a second one where you can skateboard.
Okay.
It's this song.
We can't hear him.
It's a long time ago now, darling.
It's funny and sunset.
Anyways, I was very surprised that she came to my hotel.
It was...
Can you guys hear him at all?
I heard my heart thundering.
I
could barely hear the guy.
It never gets old.
I love it so much.
The song is peak.
I agree.
As long as you can read the subtitles, I suppose.
Oh, wait.
Where's the pup?
There it is.
Let's go.
Wait, can I?
Where's the phone?
Oh.
Here is the phone.
Wait.
Where?
Where is the phone?
No!
We missed the phone!
This is fine.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, man.
Are we close?
Wait.
I guess not.
Girl, is that where we're trying to go to?
Oh my god.
We're going out of town.
Wait a second, but the purple area Purple Arrow is this way!
Am I doing the wrong thing?
Watch the railroad!
Okay, good.
Purple Arrow is a side quest.
Should I go?
Oh my god, you are getting every song in the soundtrack.
Life is beautiful!
Don't you think they make a wonderful family?
I guess so.
Including Jim, I suppose they do.
Indeed they do.
The ideal family, I'd say.
You know that I look after Isaac and Isaiah pretty often,
right?
They talk a lot when I take them out.
Yesterday, mama and papa, and this morning grandpa, always
about their family.
Just listening to them makes me feel so happy.
I don't have any brothers, you know.
Maybe I'm a little jealous of those two.
That's why when I come here, I always pay them a visit.
a second home to me I can tell deputy willie's calling again
enough about me let's get going lovely chat here in this
thunderstorm while it's absolutely terrifying outside for
some reason in the darkness I see Emily's face when I When I
first met her on the bridge, she looked so...
Oh, God.
Dignified.
Oh, there she is.
And that glimmer in our eyes when she argues every word I
say.
Oh, she's gone.
Blonde hair lit by the dawn.
He is staying on the diamond.
Oh, we're smitten!
We are smitten with her!
Holy cow!
I think some gal had coffee.
She's obsessed with the coffee she made, too.
It's like she's a...
goddess in a tight dress.
She's a goddess in a tight dress.
Damn girl, that body of yours ain't real.
He's so down bad.
York, when did this happen?
We've been here like a week, by the way.
Oh, I guess the side quest is gone.
I missed it.
That's okay, though.
I thought actually the purple arrow was going to be where it
was where the dog was taking us but
yeah it's caffeine withdrawals
oh my god we're running all the way up the hill this is
crazy you good back there Payson's keeping pace, us too.
We're good.
He would be in the clock tower, right?
That would make sense.
What a mysterious game.
Are we good?
Okay, oh.
These are marathon runners out here.
Willie, York is nearby.
this reaction.
Good job, Libby.
Can we stop running now, please?
Oh, okay.
He's zooming.
York is nearby.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
York.
York is nearby.
I'm faster than the dog.
This is crazy.
Oh, my gosh.
Emily, you need to join the Olympics.
Hey, so we took the long route here.
You weren't playing with us, were you?
George, we've found out where York is.
George?
Uh-oh.
Kasen, I'm going in alone.
Hey, hey!
You didn't forget what George said.
No, I haven't.
And that's why you get to stay out here and keep trying to
contact him.
I'm just going to check things out.
I'll stay out of danger.
Why is everybody obsessed with going in alone?
Okay, if you say so.
I'll take care of this here.
He's speaking in tongues.
Emily, don't become a goddess.
You're my goddess.
Oh, she's in the night.
Wait.
Emily can also get paid.
What do you see?
Her first zombie person!
No way.
Does she also say nice?
Please.
Nice shot.
Amazing.
Stop right there.
The game hasn't...
Okay, so we have this, like, strange purple mist that...
Does all this nonsense, but we do not know why these zombie
people appear.
we go into a nightmare world and everything what the hell
hi thomas oh yeah york emily is here oh time to say goodbye
then thomas let me tell you one more time it's not too late
i can help you just untie me and let me go if you don't The
situation will be irreversible, unfixable.
York, no situation is reversible.
Didn't you know that?
I don't know about that.
Everyone, everything proceeds along a path preordained by
fate.
Goodbye then.
I wonder who will be the next person to open this door.
Wait, why are you leaving?
Whoever that person is, will be the one to decide your fate.
Straight!
No!
I mean, yeah, what are you supposed to say?
All I can do now is wait.
All right, Tom.
Oh, wow, whoa, oh my gosh.
Why is Emily in the cursed world?
Oh, I hear so many.
I hear so many though We're Emily now you guys Whoa We're
Emily Cool Oh gosh I hear so freaking many though Oh gosh
Emily I need to be I need feedback Am I doing well or what
Emily I need feedback back nice shot amazing Emily Emily how
am I doing I still hear more but I can't tell from where
great I can't tell from where okay keep going then we're so
calm and cool and collected and we're totally comfortable
with blowing people up immediately.
Nice shot.
Oh, there's one.
Just the one I'm hearing.
Nice.
Okay, so all we have is our handgun.
That's totally fine.
What did we get?
I'll take that.
Whoa, Bill, I think it's much for the pink.
Mr. Stewart said the gas comes from the ground when it rains
from the heavy saturation.
Yeah, and the shadows are ghosts from the raincoat killings.
Oh, so they're ghosts of it.
Hence the reused models, though York has encountered them
before.
Okay, okay.
I figure, I mean, like, I remember the thing about, like,
the mist
coming back up and everything.
I just, um, wasn't sure if it was like turning townspeople
crazy or something.
Ah!
I couldn't, y'all, you were a mystery guy.
I couldn't hear you at all.
Oh, what are you holding there?
Oh.
E!
Yeah, Emily's pistol is really good.
Only takes a couple shots for these guys.
Oh.
Uh-huh.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Okay.
Don't want to die.
I don't want any more jump scares.
These are the tallest.
I don't think the clock tower was this tall.
I'm just saying.
I don't think it was this tall.
Oh, there it is.
74 flights of stairs.
Actually, though.
Oh.
Emily's getting paid today.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Wait, maybe I can blow this up.
They actually do float through the floor.
Oh, no, we took damage from that one.
I also miss York's encouragement.
They do work.
I am motivated through.
Through encouragement and good and being told a good job.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait.
Who's there?
Wait, they shouldn't be here, no?
Because this is a save room?
Who am I hearing?
First aid kit.
Alright.
Save.
Nice.
And it didn't cost us.
Yeah, wait.
Oh, no, there's only sleeping.
There's no changing.
Alright, Emily.
Is this where he's at?
It has to be.
Right.
Oh.
Wait.
Something.
There was something happening.
Some sort of music.
Oh, we're in here now.
Whoa.
Whoa!
The clock's all funky.
It's all funkified because we're in the nightmare zone.
Whoa!
Neat!
Seems a little dangerous maybe.
No.
Maybe not.
What's going on here?
Is it Thomas?
You sure took your time.
Thomas, you've got nowhere to run now.
Just surrender yourself.
Emily, I've been waiting for you.
Where's York?
Is he okay?
He's quite the handsome one, isn't he?
I liked him the moment I saw him.
Yeah.
He likes someone else, of course.
Who do you think that is?
I'm asking you if he is okay.
Answer me.
Oh, yes.
He is handsome.
But me and Carol, we love not him, but a different person.
My...
Oh, it says love G.
Grandma?
The crap.
Do you know what you're doing?
You need to talk up, Thomas.
My lovely grandma.
Nothing about yourself, nor this town.
Please don't make me shoot you.
You're a silly, sad little woman.
Don't call me that!
We're heading for devastation.
All of us.
And no one can stop it.
Oh, Thomas.
You're sick.
But there's still time.
We can get you help.
I'll help you.
You're too kind, Emily.
Don't call her a goddess.
As a goddess.
why he likes you this town is soiled Thomas we'll get you a
new dress shiny red is not your color that's right Thomas oh
my gosh Emily is so loud let's just leave here together it
was so much better back then we had so much fun Emily that
was before you came oh I won't let you have him oh you
filthy pig oh oh my god what is this oh my god wait
What am I dodging?
Wait, is this like my first boss fight, actually?
Oh.
Dodge this.
Oh, shoot.
You pig.
What am I dodging?
What are you actually sending?
Where are you?
Oh, he's up there.
Eat this.
I got this.
Okay.
Oh, I got him.
Take this!
Oh.
I don't know what I'm...
I don't know what I'm dodging at all.
Oh.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
She keeps calling her a pig!
You're so rude!
Dodge this!
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh, she keeps doing it.
I don't have a chance to...
Okay.
Oh, I got him.
You're...
I feel like the boa is going to...
I won't let you take him.
I'll show you how serious I am.
I feel like the boa is gonna get in the cogs, no?
What is this?
This song is sick, though.
This song is awesome.
Oh!
No, I won't.
Woo!
Looking pathetic, Emily.
Nice.
Oh, ow!
There we go.
I think it was a different...
Why?
Oh, shoot you.
Looking pathetic, Emily.
Oh my god, stop!
He's defined gravity.
Where'd he go?
Thomas, don't go.
Thomas.
Thomas...
Oh, there.
I don't know what you're...
Oh,
shoot.
Trying to shoot.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm just trying to shoot.
Oh, my.
I'm out of bullets.
you big you're gonna die emily no not this again this
is such a funny boss fight x looking pathetic emily did why
uh-oh oh wait i'm gonna get a med kit real quick in my mind
palace okay nice looking pathetic emily looking pathetic
emily i'm sorry to anyone named emily here it's not you it's
thomas being he's so close though thomas being a doodoo head
where is he oh there he goes
Oh, so close.
So close.
Yeah!
Thomas, don't make me shoot again.
Surrender and turn yourself in.
Emily?
Emily, I don't know.
Thomas.
Shot him in the butt.
Yeah, I did.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
That almost sounds like he's laughing.
That's enough, Thomas.
Just come over here.
Emily recorded lines in a hotel bathroom.
I don't believe...
Emily, I just...
No, wait.
I hate you so much.
Die, you skanky swine.
Oh my god!
Thank you, skanky much!
Get away!
Oh, what?
Get off!
Uh-oh.
Oh, where is it?
Oh, the suspense is killing me.
Doing all this in heels, I'm so impressed, Thomas.
Oh my!
The knife wasn't enough!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Oh.
Is that Thomas hanging there?
Why are you smiling, Kaysen?
Oh my god.
He looks like a strung up jerky.
Zach was that a gunshot?
I hope nothing terrible has happened.
Those are inside thoughts.
Those are inside thoughts, Kaysen.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do
Hi, Emily.
Hey, Willie.
Are you here with your owner?
Look like
a strung-up turkey is really just wild.
Wow, Willie is kind of the goal of this game, no?
Wow.
Okay.
What the?
Oh, do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Willy MVP I hope I don't have to change Hopefully I'm not
too stinky
What's this?
First aid kit large Alright Yeah, he can open doors too Why
did he leave us?
I kind of want him to stick around Oh, we don't need to
sleep I guess We're good
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do
Are we gonna see it?
Wait, so we're not gonna get rescued.
Like...
How far away is everybody?
Wait, we don't have our stuff either, do we?
Oh, okay, they're right in here.
Yeah, I have nothing on me.
Oh, she's down here!
Wait, do we see him?
Do we see the turkey?
What do you mean, Willie rescued you?
Oh, so true.
I'm, like, discounting Willie's efforts.
Willie's looking around, like, am I the only one who
remembered why we're here?
Hello?
Hello.
Are you okay?
Sorry for being late.
No, you're totally good.
I'm fine.
Thanks for being here at all.
I have to spend some quality time with Zach.
I heard gunshots.
Did you get our man?
York.
Thomas is dead.
Oh, I shot him.
He tried to kill me.
Thomas.
I suppose that this is...
is the fate you talked about but Emily what about the
murderer I just told you I had to shoot Thomas Thomas's
actions may have surprised you I understand that but our job
is to catch the killer isn't it you didn't let the killer
get away York are you saying that Thomas was not responsible
for the murders what law that makes no sense oh Emily are
you out of your mind what thomas was certainly neck deep in
this but he didn't kill the girls he has concrete alibis for
all three murders honestly he does he also doesn't have the
reverse peace symbol on his back these are basic facts that
for sure you haven't forgotten we have red dress ada wong at
home i need you to be strong emily if thomas is not the
killer then there is only one possibility that york gets to
kiss emily with free access to the the department files and
doesn't have an alibi at the time of the killings lo chi
himself george george is the killer wait and when did you
start thinking this i wasn't sure to start with but you saw
the picture no wait what but he doesn't have the thing in
the on his back we saw was when I became 100% positive.
But George didn't have the tattoo on his back.
Ah, right.
He doesn't have a tattoo on his back.
I mean, yeah, he did have the...
There is a pattern there.
What do you mean?
Emily, I'm not saying that the pattern was the tattoo.
What?
Remember what Harry said.
There isn't a single thing that can maintain its shape for
eternity.
And George's back is a perfect example.
Hey, you two!
Could you explain this so I can...
She's the driver!
The man is George's son!
Emily here.
I've rescued Agent York from the clock tower.
Thomas is dead.
I was forced to shoot him.
I see.
Huh.
York is a little weak, but we're heading back to the
department now.
Okay.
Yeah, wait, wasn't George saying that he liked Emily too or
something?
Didn't we...
Didn't he say something about that?
This clock tower is huge.
It does not look like this from the outside.
George is a friend of yours, isn't he?
Oh my god.
Then what we are about to do is going to be tough to deal
with.
Are you willing to go through with this?
York, I'm deputy sheriff.
This might be a small town, but I take pride in that.
Yeah!
Emily's so awesome make sure that we catch all the bad guys
in Green Bay even if it means facing an end that I would
never have hoped for okay then let's get moving this case is
going to end at the Sheriff's Department oh are you looking
at me wait did he just look at us Kason's like what the heck
what the heck is this man come on let's go with him Okay.
Chickening out now would be like, well even after eating the
appetizers.
I'm gonna see more people get killed.
I'm not traumatized enough yet.
Cat fight!
That's what this is called!
I got paid to get kidnapped and sit in a room.
Oh man.
Goodbye my beloved Thomas.
I can't believe Thomas is dead.
I can't believe it's George!
I can't believe!
Wow.
Yeah, Kason loves the drama.
Emily, I'm going in from the front.
You secure the back.
Okay.
What should I do?
Kason, stay at the entrance.
No, don't cut me out now.
I'd be some minor nameless character.
And I thought I was the cheerful sidekick that helped solve
the case.
I mean, the dog did help, so...
Naked cases.
Wait, I want to go back to being Emily.
Her gun was really good.
Her pistol was awesome.
What?
What's wrong?
besides this place being a nightmare zone oh are we are we
about to profile license george's license plate is he's the
one or something wait no way oh we're profiling it's not
it's what it's not is it oh there's like a small line in it
why it is
He's the one!
Like, wait.
If it really is.
I guess I was thinking...
What?
He's number one.
That's what I was thinking.
Zach, I thought we might get a warm welcoming.
Do I have all...
Since you cannot carry any more items...
Wait.
Okay.
Wait, wait, does that mean we can get Emily's gun because it
was moved to my toolbox?
That would be huge if so.
Not a soul in sight, though I doubt if it would have a soul
to speak of.
We just have to find a place to save them.
Hopefully here?
Oh, dang it.
Is this Ana again?
No.
Kurekos!
Yeah, this is the right way to go.
This is the right way to go.
Alright, so the office is the right way.
I don't actually are any of the doors I don't know if we're
able to go through any more of them actually I might have
just picked the only door that was open
unless that one at the very very back oh I hear them is
there one around the corner
no I guess maybe the lower as we move along or something.
Okay, well.
We only have one option.
I love the texturing in this game.
I love that fog is a flat, like, PNG.
You just see it?
Where's all these noises coming from?
That's a cracker singular.
What's this?
Observe.
Please, observe.
There we go.
It's Thomas's desk.
Why did he choose this ending?
I can't understand, Zach.
Oh, no, it's Thomas's desk!
No, Thomas!
Oh, I loved Thomas!
I'm trying to see what the picture frame is.
I'm sad.
PNG dog, no PNG fog.
Oh, here we go.
Wow.
you guys.
I'm so impatient, I think.
Okay.
Toolbox.
Let...
Oh my gosh, sorry.
It's so loud.
Let's see.
Panda bear?
What is this?
Oh, this is where we can buy more stuff.
That's right, I wanted to buy.
Oh!
And this one's new too, the assault rifle.
It's half of our money.
The katana?
Was it the saber or the katana?
Strength medium.
Strength high.
They're both durability medium.
So maybe the sword, it was really good though.
It was really stinking good.
Wait, hold on.
Finish.
Get the magnum.
Put an item away.
Let's put away the mission knife.
And the golf club.
My toolbox is full?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Well, I can still take out two things.
Take an item out.
The sheriff custom.
Now I wonder...
When we had it for Emily, it was unlimited ammo.
Will it be the same?
And we'll bring the saber.
My head is full.
How?
I only took one thing!
I took one thing!
It is.
It's unlimited.
Wait, so we now have two...
Wait, so I'm going to put away...
Why was Emily's gun so much better?
They're both...
Okay, whatever.
I'm going to put away the FBI gun, and we're going to grab
the magnum.
Throw away all the pipes.
Yeah, maybe.
Wait, hold on.
Attack low.
Attack medium!
That's why.
And it can even hold more bullets!
Amazing.
Wait.
Wait, hold on.
Take item out.
How do I get rid of them though?
How do I get rid of them?
It won't let me like throw it away.
Can you sell the panda?
Let me try.
I have multiple in my possession, okay?
Okay, hold on.
No, I can only buy.
Yes.
Okay, hold on.
I don't want it to destroy the save point.
It is losing.
If it hits something, it does.
We can throw it away while holding it.
We can.
B to throw away.
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
Okay, it's gone.
It's gone.
Okay.
We're clearing inventory right now, guys.
We're clearing inventory.
I was just gonna swing it to...
I have three crowbars.
We'll do the shovel next.
We'll do the shovel.
Break stuff.
Throw away.
Alright.
Okay.
Cool blocks.
Alright.
Okay, it took all of it.
Can I take these two?
Dang.
Okay.
That's fine.
He is really dramatic when he throws it away.
Okay.
Oh, no, not you.
Throw away.
It feels like a waste, but...
It's fine.
Probably.
Okay.
Alright.
Who left all their crowbars in here?
And golf gloves.
This guy loves golf.
Looking into it, apparently Thomas' license plate was...
T-A-2 Love G.
Or Tattoo Love G.
That's sweary for you.
Source.
Deadly Premonition Wiki.
Oh my god.
That's so funny.
I'm going to...
I'm just gonna keep the saber.
Oh wait, no, I was gonna grab the saber with me.
Steel pipe, throw away.
All right, we'll get, we'll put, now we can put away our FBI
gun and we can grab the saber.
All right, put away.
FBI custom, yes.
It's mandatory for all field agents to carry.
So if I buy the magnum
Now is our inventory full?
How's our stinky?
Are we stinky?
Looks a bit dirty.
Let's go with our agent suit.
Change.
We'll change into the agent suit.
Looks almost brand new.
Go for cleaning.
Yep, it's being washed.
Brand new, brand new.
York classic, exactly.
Exactly, exactly.
How many shots does that gun have?
Six shots.
It's got six shots.
Okay, but I'm pretty sure now.
Okay, so now I have to switch to the sheriff custom, not the
FBI custom.
Oh, that's so confusing.
I wish I could get rid of it.
Oh, wait.
Actually, I have six bullets.
I don't know if it takes more.
More than enough, though, probably.
If it ends up being a problem, we can just come back.
Or key for hidden room.
Where is a hidden room?
I guess it's pretty well hidden.
If I knew it wouldn't be hidden for sure.
Let's profile.
Look at him.
He's listening to the beat.
Okay, so George comes in.
I can't believe it's George!
We were starting to like this guy!
Look at him throwing it.
If you check the closets in this station, one is full of
raincoats.
Actually, I think I vaguely remember that.
Oh,
I thought they were right behind me.
But I just thought it was because, you know, it's raincoats.
in all the time here wow wow all right so they're in here
now i guess
are you is there someone else coming after me or oh oh yes
ah these guys are so scary let me know also if the audio
ends up being kind of loud or anything.
What's this now?
Are we gonna get it?
What's his name?
Nick out of...
Our praise is back.
Yeah!
Don't want to die.
Audio's good?
Okay.
Ah!
Oh
my gosh.
I wish I had a saber right now.
I hope they're not coming down the stairs.
I think I need to just go in.
Very slowly.
No worries.
No issues or anything.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, big guy.
Big guy.
I'm not.
Amazing indeed, right?
Nice, it was just him.
There's a guy right behind me.
Can I get him from the door?
Oh, I can.
Yes.
Amazing.
Oh, and it got rid of it, too!
Nice.
Pretty big, I'd say.
If this place had a warden, we'd ask him to lock up those
things, right, Zach?
Yeah, he dropped some loot.
Don't want to die.
They're still letting us sleep in here.
It worked.
What was that?
Tomato sauce!
Oh, I should clean up my inventory.
The policeman in the newspaper is the game developer.
Oh wait, is it really?
That's so funny.
Tomato sauce.
Sequel to toilet flair.
Wait, there's all kinds of stuff in here.
I don't necessarily want to go into every little...
What the heck?
Why is each toilet...
Oh.
I spoke too soon, but almost every toilet has a...
has a... has a prize.
It's locked, I need a key.
I want to die!
No!
It's locked.
I need a key.
Okay, well anyway.
Oh, she's in here.
Is this not what I got?
Oh.
Wait.
I need a key with 05 written on it to open this door.
Oh, we got key 1.
That's why we were able to open this one.
Oh.
I guess I think we had to probably kill more guys more guys
we kill they might drop the keys probably fine fine fine
we'll use the magnum are you gonna come down
okay okay false alarm
What?
I thought it would kill him in one shot.
Oh, yeah, he dropped one.
He dropped one.
Okay.
Watch it be the guy at the very end.
It's a stinking hallway, right?
I'm just going to use my shotgun.
Come here.
Yeah, yeah, come here.
Not that close.
Oh, I forgot these guys are tough.
These guys do take a couple hits, no matter.
No matter how many, how good your gun is.
Oh, jeez.
It's gonna be like this now, isn't it?
Right away.
You know what?
We'll go back to the sheriff question.
It's fine.
Maybe we can get rid of this pile.
Hey!
Ah!
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Oh, jeez.
Oh, I think it's a never-ending pile.
No.
Amazing.
Great.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
No, no.
I think so.
Okay, I got to run through.
Sure.
Yes.
And don't get hit behind from behind.
Amazing.
Okay.
Ah!
Ouch!
Run!
Ah!
They're all on me!
Oh, I wish I had my sword right now.
Oh my gosh.
Great.
Bullseye.
Yes.
Amazing.
Oh, scary.
We did it somehow?
Did anybody drop the key?
Great.
Oh, I think we need to go into some of these doors then,
maybe.
Oh, yeah, we do!
Some of these... Okay, they do open now.
I see, I see, I see.
Somebody in?
Somebody in here?
Coffee black.
I can't take anything.
My inventory's so full.
Don't be in here.
Oh,
I'm trying to shoot him, but it won't let me.
Full of crowbars.
Right in the peeping.
Oh, he dropped one.
Six.
I was a good jump scare.
Again?
Another one?
Don't go all over the place.
Ha!
Kill you!
Leave me a present, leave me a present.
Come on.
Give me a key as a treat.
I wonder if only one guy per room gives a key.
I wonder, I guess there's probably someone in here too, yep.
Of course.
Oh, why is iframe?
Crazy.
Okay, so basically you had to, like, have made the correct
choice.
That's kind of stinky.
Kind of stinky.
Okay.
We go back out.
Oh, wait.
This is where we saw the raincoats, wasn't it?
Okay.
Yes.
And they are all red.
Look at that.
There's only the one guy, right?
No.
Another guy.
Come on.
Holy.
Right on me.
Can he give me a little treat?
I
do keep coming Except when I don't
Maybe someone here
Please?
Yes?
No!
Look at them, no!
It's way too obvious.
Don't worry, sir.
Corporate will find you soon enough.
That's so funny.
I can't believe it.
Sir, culprit.
Turkey sandwich.
Do you think that's Thomas' last sandwich?
It's probably delicious, then.
Who is in here making all this noise?
Captain Obvious over here.
Leaving all of his red braincoats in the same room.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, what if it's in the kitchen?
Can I even go in here?
No.
Locker room, I kill him.
He needs like 50 of them too, apparently.
I kind of believe it.
Oh my gosh.
They're so loud.
You're so loud.
Please give me a key.
Cell 5.
I don't need no pickles.
Wait, what is this?
Is that another door?
Oh, it's a mirror!
Yeah?
No, cell 2.
The item pickup noise is the exact same as the noise
ruffians make in Viva Pinata when they throw up bad candy,
and I can't unhear it.
the rom that noise
do do that one
maybe they took it from the same sound pack I don't know
I will use a small first aid kit since we're full anyway
Might as well.
Okay.
We've gotten every key, but at this point, I think.
I don't know if that worked, actually.
Open?
Have we been in this room before?
I don't know if I have.
Stay down.
Oops.
Wait, maybe I got him?
Nope.
There's two more guys down there.
Hopefully this clears up after this guy.
Yeah, nice.
Alright.
I will take some magnum bullets.
Thank you very much.
Yes?
Oh.
It got it.
Whoa!
The shotgun is so powerful sometimes.
Please, please!
Self!
Are we for real?
I think I do actually have every key.
Except five.
At this point.
What's over here?
Oh, the coffee.
And then this doesn't open.
I can observe it.
Emily will handle this, though I hope we can deal with this
ourselves, right, Zach?
Right.
Ah!
He scared me, I didn't know he noticed me.
He freaked me out.
Oh, did I get him?
No?
I shot you twice!
What is this?
The game is...
I'm gonna go...
Oh, I'm going in there.
I was gonna go save again.
Um, the game is sabotaging me a little bit.
What if O5 is behind one of the others?
Like, one of the other...
Uh, cells?
It didn't seem like it, though, because there was nothing
else in all the other cells, so...
I also want to check on my...
Um...
My ammo.
Like, does it automatically take out ammo for me?
There we go.
Yeah, I wanted to grab the shotgun bullets.
Let's see.
Oh.
20.
Magnum bullets at 52.
Okay, we'll start using those again.
Let me see if I can buy more.
Because it would be nice if I could.
Let's see.
Oh, I can, I can.
For machine gun and assault rifle.
Oh, wait, here we go.
Just kidding.
I'm a liar.
Yippee!
Okay.
Yeah, the shotgun is nice because you get, like, some of the
guys get splash damage, so you can kill two at once.
Sometimes.
Is that enough?
I'll double check how much I have.
Let's go.
High spread and high damage make it a really good gun.
Exactly, exactly.
Alright, nice.
Let's get back out there!
Okay, we're looking for key to cell 5.
But I've cleared out, I feel like, every single room at this
point.
Besides the guy that keeps...
Spawning forever.
Unless, like, here?
Ta-da.
I went into storage.
Material room.
Kitchen we can't go into.
It's so loud all of a sudden.
I guess I'll just go back down stairs i
hear somebody
oh who am i hearing
oh you know there are like nasty what's it called in here
like spots where they might come up out of the ground so
maybe yeah maybe maybe
Maybe, maybe.
But why would a prisoner have the key?
It's my question.
What is it?
Stabilizer.
One could be a...
One could be a police officer, though.
This one's...
This one I went in there, right?
Maybe?
This one also?
He was a model prisoner.
He yoinked it off of the guard, maybe.
Oh?
I can't see.
You did?
Yeah.
No way.
What?
Oh my god.
You really?
I should have known it would be a significant...
They were like, hey, hey, you can't, you can't leave this
one.
This room's important.
We promise, we promise you'll want to go into this room.
Soft lock preventer.
Always the last place you look for it.
There is a save right here.
She didn't know Clip.
She's a ghost.
Alright, guys.
Oh!
Wait, what just happened?
Uh...
Here, only the color of the wall is different.
There must be something.
Wait, what's happening?
Flesh the toilet?
Does that unlock it?
Okay.
It looks like a door.
I don't know what else he wants from me.
I realized.
It's like the...
It's...
What's it called?
The...
The boxes and stuff that you push.
Looks like the door wasn't locked.
Okay, then I'm going in.
But it says it's a hidden door, but it is...
oh no wait another puzzle or something oh
my gosh there's so many guys
don't walk down oh okay they won't this works too maybe oh
shoot
oh my
gosh Nice!
Whoa!
That was nice!
That was good.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Is there anyone else?
Oh, there is!
He's got a gun!
Did that guy over there die?
I guess so.
Oh, there you are.
You blend it in.
True camouflage.
Camouflage 100.
I was like, what's the floating orb?
What's the floating orc?
Carol's ear rings.
Not earrings, the ear rings.
Seems that a kind of devilish ceremony occurred in this
room.
What's over here?
Oh, yeah, take that.
A mob gauntlet instead of a boss room?
Is this silk song?
Ah, this.
Interesting.
I think we're getting somewhere, Zach.
Is that what he's about to say to?
Say it.
Her ear rings.
Octocam user.
It's so true.
The crowbar is spinning around in the background.
Let's profile!
rings.
What was that?
I mean, having a sip?
Yeah.
I'm having a sip of some water in my water bottle.
That is some interesting hairbrushing sounds.
Carol!
Oh!
Why is she brushing her hair like?
Why does it sound like...
I was gonna say, why does it sound wet?
They got a deal on those dresses.
Uh-oh, are we gonna have to fight Carol?
The shop that sold these dresses is like, I'm getting bought
out, baby!
for life
carol carol are you okay george george did this to you
thomas oh my god her dying message thomas he's dead i i shot
him i i had to sorry were substitutes what carol
george loves carol not carol oh you can hear oh my god oh my
god she's feeding her on the machine no They get you!
Oh
no, Emily!
Kaysen!
Kaysen, quick!
Kaysen can hear us?
They saw from Into With Love and thought, I want some of
those dresses.
Wow!
For real!
Emily, no!
Emily, Emily ate the bad scene!
No, no!
Why what took you so long?
York!
Oh my god!
Kasen's out there like...
Rush to the hospital.
She needs a full stomach and liver cleansing.
York, you need to come too.
She needs...
No, I have to take care of something.
Yeah, we have to find the killer.
Also, like, go.
But I can't take her alone.
Please, Kasen.
Okay, okay, I'll do it.
Fast.
But if something happens, don't blame me, okay?
What the?
What's gonna happen?
Oh my gosh, please give Willie a seatbelt or something.
I've been this emotional in a long, long time.
Can you tell, Zach?
What's gonna happen?
He's like, I can't take her by myself.
But if something happens, Oh my god.
He's here, he's here.
Oh, we finally get to see him!
Oh my god.
As the raincoat killer.
What?
I definitely did not walk down there with a machine gun, but
okay.
The throne of abyss.
Evil George.
It's a little loud.
Whoa!
Bro is aura farming.
AR aura farming.
I think it's cooler with the pistol.
I feel more in control.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I want to see Zach deal.
Previously during the investigation.
Thomas, you've got nowhere to run now.
Just surrender yourself.
You won't have it your way.
I won't let you take him.
those screenshots oh my god all of these are screenshots are
you okay yo york are you saying that thomas was not
responsible for the murders love chi himself crazy
oh my god
oh i supposed to be looking at something else
We're going in?
Previously on Deadly Permission Z.
Yeah.
I think I made a joke.
Is it George joke?
Oh, I think I made a is it George joke when we saw the
tattoo?
Jokes on me.
For real, though.
What?
Why is everything...
Wait, are we for real profiling right now?
No?
Hey, nobody here.
I'm thinking of asking Emily out for dinner.
If she survives, if we survive.
Nothing too fancy.
Just somewhere where we can relax.
You know what?
Nick's diner might be a good idea.
I think I owe him a nice big tip, too.
Oh, my God.
Wait though, I do actually have to pee real quick, so I'll
be right back.
Sorry, I know it's at such a climax.
I had so much water today though.
I was doing a lot of recording, so I'll be right back, I'll
be right back.
Alrighty.
Showdown.
Commence.
Okay.
Thanks for... Why give over?
Showdown commands!
Welcome back, thank you!
Let's go, let's go.
Oh.
Wait, I'm back to the FBI custom.
Get rid of that.
Well, showdown, maybe?
Eh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that's something I can't do.
Oh, jeez.
That was...
Oh, shoot.
You both got it.
Both are up.
I get both.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, that was scary.
Let's...
Is this the same place?
Oh.
It's so different, although...
Ah, really?
Don't want to die!
Oh my gosh!
Give me the money?
Oh
my gosh!
Is it just a loop?
Yeah, the cops, they teleport.
Freaky.
They're really fast.
Alright.
We're just gonna...
Oh!
I think I hear him in here.
Is this a loop, though?
I'm just double-checking.
Pretty sure it is, but...
Yeah.
We'll ignore that guy.
I think I...
Yeah.
Yeah, we went kind of the easier way without all the stuff,
the blocks we had to break and everything.
And push around.
These are so annoying.
Wait.
Oh, I can't push it.
You can do it.
Yep.
Keep doing it.
You're going to break it.
Yep.
Come on, York.
You got this?
Actually, I don't know.
Can you stop pushing that?
I don't want to...
Yeah.
I think the infinite ammo makes this way easier.
What did we get?
Stabilizer.
What is the stabilizer?
Plately restores his pulse rate and also helps keep it low
for long.
Okay.
Is anybody in here?
Is this Thomas's desk, technically, I guess?
Okay.
Is this Thomas's desk?
I'm asking the same questions?
Huh.
It's just so distorted in here or something.
Is this Emily's desk?
She's got candy all over.
And lots of cookies.
And lots of candy.
Would this be Emily's desk?
Has there ever been a moment when you need to lower the
heart rate?
If you run too much?
Yes.
But, uh...
Nothing that I've had issues with.
I can hear it.
I can hear it again.
The axe.
What is this?
What?
Ah!
Decorates like Gaston!
Is someone gonna come out of here?
Shockingly, no.
Okay, just a steel pipe.
So we need to get...
The door is jammed by multiple deer antlers.
Force is not an option here.
There must be a way to open it, Zack.
Oh, like in the old one, the combat was way messier, so you
probably ran away more.
That's really fair, right?
Yeah.
It's upside down.
Is this some hidden significance to this?
Do I shoot it?
Alright.
And here they go.
That's actually why I took out this one first.
Is there more than one?
Okay, maybe it's just the one.
Nice.
Actually, I think it took out that pile too.
Are there more?
Oh yes, there's another one.
I forgot to...
I forgot to reload!
Don't kill me!
Oh my gosh, my M.
Amazing.
Bullseye.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Very nice.
What'd you drop?
First gauge?
Oh, shotgun.
Yeah, we will take these gladly.
I keep reading the 12 gauge and I get 12 bullets, but I
don't think that's what's happening here.
And so I honestly have no idea how many...
Oh, you just came from the wall.
Okay.
Where?
Oh, you're right there.
Okay.
Don't do it.
Difficult day for us Argentine's Berminto House.
Oh no!
No, don't be sad.
Hey, you got second.
That's always something.
Yeah, I do have the magnum too.
12 gauge is the size of the bullet.
I know, but I keep thinking I'm getting 12.
But like, I see 12 and I'm like, oh, I'm getting 12 more
bullets, you know?
Not that it's the size of it.
You know what I mean, though?
Well, it's okay.
Honestly, I'm like, I don't know how many I have.
Truly.
Let's do, let's go back to...
We can go back to Magnum.
Well, how many?
Shotgun has seven.
Maybe Magnum wasn't as good as I thought it would be.
That's okay, though.
He's here!
George!
George, take off your outfit.
You look ridiculous.
Actually, I like his look.
I came from this door, and now I'm going back in.
Okay.
Is there anything down here?
What's this door though?
I'm going in through this one first.
I might have made a mistake.
Oh wait.
Wait.
Oh, I stopped it.
He does have infinite axes.
I'm not even hitting him.
Now I think about it.
Do I have to get him in the head?
I thought I was doing damage.
Can I leave?
Just had to get close to him.
Ah!
Wait!
What was in the other door then?
Somehow he managed to flee.
Let's hunt him down.
I'm gonna move over a little.
Now, just think about going ahead.
Oh, that's what he said.
Okay.
Oh, I gotta reload.
There
we go.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
I'm evading.
Oh, nice.
Uh.
Evade!
It works.
I'm rushing at him again.
But I'm really...
The showdown time with him is close!
Kicks down the door.
Shuts it close.
First aid kit.
I will take that.
The way the door shuts by.
It's too funny.
It's too good.
Oh, this game is such a treat.
I love the graffiti here in the nightmare world.
Who doing that?
Albert Whisker at home!
Oh, you'll give George some respect.
Irrespect George.
Surely there's a...
Wait.
Maybe I should have gone back.
Or tried to.
Oh, well.
Definitely no way to now.
I probably wouldn't have let me before anyway.
I was just trying to save.
Some of these we can open.
I imagine there's...
Oh, that's the door we need to go in.
into.
Let's try this one then.
I will not.
Oh,
please apologize to Mr. Stewart's attendant.
No!
Wait, where are we?
What's that sound?
This is the things that are gonna come from the walls.
I hate those.
I'm confused.
I thought George was The Zodiac Killer.
Are there guys in here?
No.
Oh, okay.
I guess we'll go this way.
It says it's the important way to go.
Oh, it's locked.
I need a key to open it.
Oh, of course it is.
Of course it is.
Okay.
Dang it.
It's gonna be the wall ghost, I think.
Les?
All right.
Let's go down through here.
Let's take it a little slower.
See what doors are open.
What was it?
What was
that?
What is that?
I'm freaked out actually.
Whoa, here we go.
What is my suit?
Okay, am I stinky?
Am I stinky?
Looks almost brand new.
Brand spanking new, I'm looking sharp.
Nice and clean.
Can I take out the shotgun shells?
Oh, okay, I'm pretty much full then, nice.
Do I even have any large ones?
It's hard to say.
No.
I
don't think I need to sleep or eat or anything.
Nope.
I'm good.
Alright.
Let's save.
Yeah, gotta look our best for the showdown.
Hee hee.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Are we gonna kiss?
Curvy-tailed flying squirrel keys!
Oh!
The squirrel keys!
I remember this when we were looking for the squirrels!
Oh my gosh!
The callback.
It's gonna come out of the hole.
It is.
I'm waiting for the vines to pop up in the middle of the
room.
There it is.
There they are.
Oh,
I think we got it.
Wow, that was really fast.
Oh, there's a second one.
Bro, curse.
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Could have been way worse.
That could have been so terrible.
Where's the nice shots, York?
Seriously.
Oh.
Where do these guys come from?
Excuse me.
Oh!
The music got so loud all of a sudden.
Maybe the Magnum is awesome.
I saw you're doing a concert next month.
I'd love to go, but I can't have surgery this month.
Probably won't be able to do next September.
Oh, Influx.
Good luck with your surgery.
Good luck.
I know all will go well.
Here we go.
What was that?
Okay, here's somebody behind this door.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Uh, do I have my shotgun?
Yeah, I was going to try and get them both at the same time.
You're still alive!
No.
Are you?
I'm gonna say it.
Nice!
This one was locked, or yeah, okay.
Oh, it looks awfully creepy in here.
Every door I can't.
thinking is this it is this the door every door i'm like
this is it ah oh
somebody died i didn't even notice they're dead they're
dying and i'm i'm not even if a if a zombo dies and nobody
is around to witness it oh
yeah sheriff custom nice shot thank you
I think he...
Does he specifically, like, tell you nice shot and stuff
when you kill him?
Okay.
When you kill him...
Not this way.
With the pistol?
Trying to be careful through here.
A little nervous.
Okay, we're good.
Okay.
There was nothing over there except money, I think.
That's just the headshots.
Okay.
Thanks, I wish...
The streaming tickets were available now.
I can't wait to see you girls.
Particularly Kiki Himay.
It feels like you're since her last B-day.
Yeah!
There will be streaming tickets, though.
I believe.
So.
If you are so inclined.
We'd love to have you watching.
I'm also very excited to meet Kiki Himay.
She's so cute.
Okie dokie.
I'm gonna get the shot going back.
up for in here.
We've been through all these places before.
And it's so quiet now.
Look at this.
Kind of freaky.
I remember this room being filled with guys before.
I'll do the, I'll do the, I'll do this one.
Hold on one second.
I'm waiting for a new pair of headphones to be delivered.
They were!
Wait, can I go get them real quick?
I'll be right back.
Never mind.
Never mind, they're at my mailbox.
They're not in front of my door, they're at my mailbox.
Dang it.
Oh, I'm glad nobody attacked me.
I was... I didn't even realize it.
Oh, let's take the shotgun shells for Shulwar?
The Koss ones?
Yeah.
I'm excited for them.
Chocolate!
Is this it?
Oh, I'm evading.
Evade!
I don't even know if I actually have to click it, you know?
But it does make it...
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude,
dude, dude.
Okay, for that time.
Is this the showdown?
For real?
Oh, shoot.
Uh, wait, maybe not.
It's showing me trying to get to the door again.
What does this mean?
Are we... Stop running away!
It shuts the door.
Let's end the raincoat killer legend here, Zack.
Yeah, let's do it.
George is being a little slippery freakazoid.
That's what he's doing.
Oh, can we actually do that, please?
Because he's so annoying me.
He's running all over the place.
Like, George, come on.
Let's, I challenge you to a duel.
We will settle this like honorable men.
I had like something in my throat.
All right.
See, even that was a headshot, but he didn't say, Like,
let's try with the magnum.
Oops.
Well, if I could get a headshot.
If I could get a headshot.
That was a headshot!
I think he doesn't say it unless it's, uh...
Whoa, wait, what is this?
I think he doesn't say it unless it's his pistol.
Yeah, just the handgun, yeah.
Oh, after he died though, maybe.
I don't know.
Is this actually it?
I don't want to be in the way, but he always has his POV.
And I can't pause to, like, get out of the way for you guys,
so.
Hmm?
Cool.
Wow!
Ouch!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, he does say it.
Okay.
Never mind, he does say it.
They're, they're like in.
Yes.
I think he's dead.
No?
Oh, yes he was.
Dang it.
My bad.
Nice.
Okay.
Am I supposed to crawl through one of these or...
Oh, this one is open.
what is this like death trap this takes him out one hit
that's crazy oh oh my job let's get him
shoot nice amazing right yeah i'm so good I'm the target
practice for these guys.
It is a slow death, yeah.
But they are dying.
They are dying.
We're getting them.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, can I get him?
Can I get him first?
Can I get...
There we go.
Very good.
Okay.
That was fun!
Woohoo!
Oh, that was so fun.
Huh?
I heard something like being gross in here.
Oh.
Okay, there it goes.
Anybody in there?
I'm observing.
The way it's time.
Totally blocked by red vines.
I can't see inside at all.
Our little guest must be hiding somewhere, though.
Wait, which way did I come from?
Am I still looking for him?
Oh, maybe in here?
Is this the only one?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
We're in the...
Okay, we're in, like, the nightmare version of the cell we
went into with the hidden door.
So we are going to go, like, fight him in that area.
That's kind of cool.
I was looking for a phone.
dramatic turnaround.
Don't...
Too close.
It's fine.
I want to see George do the finger wag.
Yeah, we know it's him already.
Come on!
They should Scooby-Doo chase.
I agree.
This room is huge and full of money!
Hahaha!
Why is it full of my...
I'll try not to lose the atmosphere.
There's like all these holes in the wall, too.
Is it going to fill it with poison gas or something?
Something over there.
I'll just keep going.
I have so many items, honestly.
What a cool room.
Oh, that looks like a...
Uh, pickaxe.
Nice.
Purple mist, perhaps.
Wouldn't that be crazy?
Here we go.
I did- I was good!
I avoided all the money, you guys.
Oh!
Should we shave?
No, we've gotten this whole time.
We've got...
Turkey sand.
how hungry am I anyway we could eat we could eat we could
have oh I thought that was a pizza she's a my cherry pie I
stuffed my face yeah let's stuff my face yeah nice and then
we'll sleep we'll take like a two hour nap or something a
light sleep should be good nice okay
take our turkey sandwich the sinner sandwich and we're gonna
eat this too we're gonna be so ready turkey an unbelievably
delicious turkey sandwich will satisfy a large amount of my
okay we don't need that much maybe i do a green tomato
sure now we're totally full everything's good
how's my suit Are we going to look good for George?
Oh, it looks almost brand new, no problem.
Even though I slept in it.
Awesome.
I don't think we got anything else.
Oh, I did.
Okay.
I'm, like, totally full on shotgun, Chelsea.
Let's get some more, uh, Magnum.
Bullets.
It doesn't say how many you get.
Oh, two.
You get two of them.
Shee!
She's a pricey.
Stinky for George.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
We're full on Magnum Bullet.
Wait, what?
How, though?
I've definitely used...
I don't know.
I'm confused.
I'm confused how it works, to be honest.
It says only two, but clearly it's more.
Here we go!
outside in the rain is this it is this it oh and his like
bdsm freaky welcome to green veil agent francis york borg ah
i finally got to see the real green veil i knew you country
folk were shy i took you long enough to show me who you
really are york this is a wonderful and powerful town
especially when it is raining i always get depressed when it
rains especially in this town i'm turning it up they're
really quiet this town has two great treasures do you know
what they are york those seeds are one of them and the women
but i don't think they deserve to be called a treasure an
ordinary man never appreciate their true value but you'll
agree with my selection on the second wait is he actually
gonna say it I don't disagree with treasure number two Emily
sparkles like a precious gem this town changed since she
came here the goddess from the city gave us the fruit of
knowledge and gave us sin She brought the internet.
When I first saw her, I realized I was such a fool.
A fool?
A fool for being satisfied by the petty girls from this
countryside town.
She...
Ah, George, I agree you were a fool, and you are a fool,
even now.
Shut it, York.
She was a beautiful city woman.
I'm a country bumpkin.
Becky, Diane, and Carol.
They all died right in front of you.
Wait, he actually killed them too.
Was that on purpose?
Could we save even one of them?
I guess it was, wasn't it?
You're the worthless fool here, and that's what proves it.
But me, unlike you, I am strong.
I have power.
It had to be, though.
My mother taught me.
The strong, who can overpower others, is always correct and
right.
His teeth!
Holy cow!
I stepped on my face with her stiletto heels because she had
power.
When the heel pierced my cheek, I learned to respect her.
We're just having a smoke break.
Since then, I obtained power of my own and found my own
disciples.
I became divine.
All I need now is that goddess of faith.
I'm grabbing with my hands.
I want Emily in her stiletto heels
The goddess won't smile for you anymore George
York have you ever shot down a deer?
Oh It's so different from shooting a man deer hunting is
great They can be erotic creatures those Black eyes, firm
hips, and slender legs.
Kind of makes a point.
I'm sorry, especially dear.
Hello?
Did you know, York,
I shot them full of bullets.
They still remain standing.
First, I thought they were zombies, but when I snuck up on
one, cut its stomach out.
The seeds, they were eating the seeds.
The red seeds.
Those seeds made those deer invincible.
George, no Olympics for you.
You'll fail the doping test.
You'll be good food for wild animals.
Shut your crap, Torque.
I have these seeds because I chose them.
They come to me, and that proves my divinity.
Oh!
You can take the red seed or the red seed.
Weirdly.
Oh, oh, you're missing.
Oh, you're dropping so many.
Oh, it's
Like three fell in your mouth whoa
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Is this like gonna be fighting Armstrong?
Oh my god.
This is the mark my mother gave me Proof of power the red
tree.
Oh, it's a red tree red tree.
It's not an upside down That's the mark of child abuse.
That's no use, York.
Carol's death gave me eternal strength.
Whoa, he grew hair and everything.
It's surging through my body.
I can no longer be killed.
Oh yeah, Carol was the last one, huh?
It wasn't Emily.
Orange, honored?
I will be the first to congratulate him for my new powers.
Dear.
You said that awfully quietly.
Win, win, win, win, win.
Oh.
Okay.
I probably had to shoot the thing on his back, I bet,
because it's glowing.
I just have to be fast.
I'm evading!
I'm pressing E.
A B.
Eternal strength is a given maternal bulletproofness.
Great question.
Oh my gosh, please.
I wish I were faster.
Come on, come on.
Oh, shoot.
Come on.
No, no!
Come on, George.
Wait,
the soundtrack is awesome.
some.
I don't know how I evaded it by going towards it.
I'm sure?
Going to crush you.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I'm so close next to him.
Okay, okay, come on.
I gotta get one hit in.
Yeah!
You think you're so clever.
Whoa, that did mega damage.
That did so much damage though.
Going to crush you.
How is...
He keeps having one thought.
Oh, come on, man.
Please.
Oh, please.
So clever.
Can I get him like right here?
Oh, dang it.
I'm going to crush you.
I love when George says I'm going to crush you.
I love when George says I'm going to George you.
Going to crush you.
Aw, you didn't say it.
Come over here.
Yeah.
Watch this, George.
Watch this.
Come over here.
Come on, George.
Get over here.
Let me see.
The rest of you are back.
It's too hard to get it.
Okay.
When he, like, does this, it's easier.
There we go.
Maybe, please, please.
I'm glad it's B every time I just keep spamming
Come on, George Let me see her back
I wonder if I could Oh yeah, I can't avoid it Okay, so you
have to dodge it That's crazy work.
No!
You jerk!
It's a homing axe, actually.
Come on!
Stop!
Turning!
Okay, this is my shot.
Wait, but he's dead!
No?
Oh, no you don't.
Unless...
Uh...
Getting Anna and Becky involved was all too easy.
Phase two?
Carol and Thomas built a secret club for me.
All we had to do was tell them about it.
And they were giddy to join us immediately.
The freaky siblings.
I've got plenty more guys.
Amazing results.
Let me tell you.
They went for learn.
My cats.
The music is so loud.
You'd think that he would be, like, more booming and evil.
So I made my decision.
She would be the first sacrifice for my immortality.
So clever.
George, your poetic prose is a bit confusing.
He reword this so it makes sense.
as your first victim so you could be a first-to-communic
murderer and you framed thomas so it looked like he did
treated as a substitute for emily jason mimosa jason mimosa
In love with you, George.
He was in love.
Oh, my.
You're making me cry.
What?
He's the one who told me about the rainbow killer.
About how to become divine, too.
Divine.
He didn't believe any of it.
He told me.
It all made sense.
Because of the deer and the seeds.
Looks like he's slowly turning into Bowser.
Why was I born in such a run-down dump?
Why did my mother beat me every day?
Why didn't Emily want me?
Oh, George.
You just move?
I don't know.
You can't go somewhere else.
He's mutating into a rock star.
Is he gonna summon a guitar?
What's happening?
What?
Oh my god!
He's really becoming Bowser!
Wait, show me the hair.
Show- he's super Saiyan!
It's an imagination like that.
You belong in the zoo.
Hollywood Zoo.
What does that mean?
This guy belongs in a zoo.
The Hollywood Zoo.
You got him, York.
Got him.
I'm taking it serious, York.
Oh, my gosh.
Let's do this
again.
Is it the same fight, but...
Oh, my gosh.
Please end this.
Nanomachines, York.
new nanomachines were made out of out of red seeds who knew
that I wonder if I can get him while he's oh shoot no oh my
god I can't I can't reload I don't have time.
There we go.
Okay.
I think he's gonna run at me.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, I was trying to get it.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
I didn't bring of my large ones.
Uh-oh.
That's fine.
Six shots, I mean, though, reloading is exhilarating.
Absolutely.
I need you to not go this way, though.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, when you...
Oh my gosh, I can't see.
Ugh.
Okay.
I need to be more precise, maybe.
It's not possible for me to die anymore.
Says you.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh my god, no.
No, I'm so bad at the game.
No, he does, like, the Sonic pose, and I should be able to
get him.
Hello, Raiders.
Thank you.
We're in the final boss.
battle please please please oh that did mega damage oh nice
nice nice that did way crazy damage holy cow thank you for
the good thing sorry i'm in i'm in mid battle so it's a
little tough but thank you
oh i need to reload again
It's phase two, but...
It's not possible for me to die anymore.
Please, please, please.
Oh, I think we got him!
Why?
Yeah!
Mama, I didn't do anything bad.
Why?
Why are you doing this to me?
Oh,
he?
Mr. Stewart?
You see, Landon gave me the wonderful present!
And it filled me with confidence.
And that was when I realized.
What?
The locket!
You need this?
Why are you so concerned about this locket?
That's right, we never got an answer.
for this oh my gosh phase three that's what he that's what
he told me so cool oh my god oh i can't move wait i can't i
actually can't move wait am i supposed to move Wait, what
the heck?
Am I supposed to be able to move?
Show
these axe.
Oh, let's try it.
Okay.
Oh, that was scary.
The game is so buggy I couldn't tell if it was a bug or not.
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
No.
You're a first-degree murderer and I'm a federal agent.
George, of course you're going to lose.
Oh, my eyes.
Whoa!
Kulabara!
Oh, we're out of the...
Oh my god, wait.
It wasn't even raining for real.
That's so freaky.
Oh, the P-Sign Shadow!
Oh my gosh.
That's so...
What?
God.
It's... It's... It's too good.
I...
Yorg, no!
So good.
He became the tree.
Oh.
Ah!
It's too good.
I'm still getting paid.
Let's go.
Wow... Oh, sorry.
I was like flailing my arm so much I hit my mic now into our
mind palace to deal with our trauma what is this oh
Valentine Morgan our mom hats off swearing too good actually
too good
you will also be able to return back soon The symbolism was
so strong, York collapsed.
I will.
I'm gonna stop being a baby.
Very soon, you'll be able to go back to where you came from.
Are you laughing?
Hi, Anna.
Thanks!
The ladies love me!
What the hell?
Wait, Emily's gotta be at the end of the line, right?
No kisses for me?
I'm just a kid, come on.
Watch me run with my stubby legs.
No way, is that Thomas right there?
Okay, Carol.
You also need to have more fun.
I'll play with you a little if you like.
Oh, okay.
Thanks.
I'm leaving now.
Papa.
Expect no praise.
You did nothing but your duty.
But I love when you praise my shooting.
No, no, I do expect a praise.
I live for the applause, applause, applause.
I live for the applause, applause, live for the applause,
applause.
No!
But, but, Bullseye.
Well done.
Mommy.
I'm sure your father wants to congratulate you.
Does he?
Dorygo, thank you.
Oh, he doesn't.
Let's ask him again.
Maybe he wants to.
Expect an O'Praise.
You did nothing but your duty.
If I don't run, I'm like the slowest walker ever.
He's so mean.
She lied.
She lied to us.
She has a...
I'm sorry, but I can't allow you to go with yourself.
Jason, figurine.
There is still something you need to do.
Open that envelope.
Who is this?
This is Mr. Stewart.
He's just not in his wheelchair with his mask on.
I have no idea what this could say.
It could literally say pee-pee-poo-poo.
I would be like, well, that's the game.
I don't know.
I don't know any or I could say little boys.
I'm the envelope I'm the letter what
Huh Oh my gosh.
Oh what was your name?
Oh the doctor.
How long have I been out?
A whole day plus ten hours or so I wanted to challenge you
to a game, but you know you asleep for 10 hours for a whole
day in 10 hours emily what she hurt she hasn't come into the
hospital what what i told kason to bring her here kason oh
kason came i'm he's the one who brought you here which
reminds me he asked me to give you this oh my god
what is it i don't know he just asked me to hand it to you
after you woke up he went you solved the case right hey do
you want to play some chess when george said he made me do
it was it casein i have an urgent issue i need to attend to
and i need to leave the hospital
oh my god zach i have a bad feeling about this the coffee
warned us i guess usha doesn't know what the symbol is yeah
which would absolve him of all any of suspicion probably oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
Oh, key from Kaysen.
And the...
What the hell is that?
I didn't, I didn't get my...
Zach, I'm getting a really bad feeling about all this.
Uh...
I truly believe George was larder, though you were after...
Oh shoot, I'm going the wrong way.
Now the dogs are evil even?
Is true at all?
The answer to the mystery of those red seeds.
seeds.
See you're on this town.
I'm sure of that.
No, you haven't!
I've been away alone since I slept through an entire day.
God, I'm lost.
All we can do is go to the location written in Kaysen's
letter.
Yes, we're going.
4,000 yards away, okay.
I took a wrong turn, guys.
Because the dog freaked me out.
Okay, we're going.
Okay, I think this...
Is this guy going to be chasing us the entire entire time.
Okay, luckily our car doesn't have like a damage or anything
on it.
Okay, send, oh, we should have known.
Why didn't we?
You know what?
I even said it was him from the beginning.
When we first met him, and then I was like, oh, it would be
too obvious.
Okay.
The
hominous music was in the cutscene.
Yeah, the guy with the red seed, exactly, right?
Like, he never explained why he sold it.
You can run into these demon dogs if you stay out too late
at night.
No kidding.
Oh, I'm glad I didn't.
I was a good girl and I went to bed at my proper bedtime.
Can you kill them?
Forest Kaysen.
FK in the coffee.
It was there the whole time.
Our first lead.
Our very first lead.
Oh, God.
This guy.
Oh, no.
George just fell for it.
He was an easy target.
Okay, bye.
Should have listened to the coffee.
Wait, uh...
Uh...
Maybe I'm going the right way still.
Maybe I turn, like, here.
Cake Princess.
Who?
Wait,
I might have gone the wrong way.
Uh...
Oh, looky.
Wait.
Am I doing?
Okay, yeah.
I was trying to remember how to break.
Hey!
Was that the dog?
Leave me alone!
Hopefully I'm going the right way.
Luckily, there's no like carols on the road trying to knock
me.
Trying to knock me off or anything.
Trying to run into me.
Okay.
Okay, we're still in the right direction.
Oh my god, go away!
Demon dog!
Go away!
We're still technically getting closer.
I didn't look at the map at all that they gave.
So I'm not quite sure where they have me going.
Oh gosh, okay.
Over this way.
Okay, I'm like so, I'm so locked in.
Trying to get through this.
Okay.
Long distance?
Let's go.
Oh, here we go.
Excuse me.
I'm pulling in.
Okay.
George's house.
With a suspiciously large red tree in there.
Oh.
Why is everything like this though?
Oh god.
This is not nightmare area, is it?
Back of his house is covered in red vines.
Oh wait, maybe it is a nightmare area.
I guess we're just a total nightmare area.
It doesn't matter.
It's like almost normal.
It's normal enough, though.
Okay.
This is most strange, Zach.
I thought the story was all over.
Me too!
But it looks like there's something else before we get to
see the ending.
Look underneath.
Oh, I hear something.
Oh, I thought we were gonna, like, peek, not open the whole
thing.
Okay, hold on.
before we do that.
What is going on?
I am, George.
You lived like this?
More twists than before this drama unfolds.
Truly.
Hey.
What's the set?
Did someone really cook in this kitchen?
The health officers would turn pale if they saw that.
Maybe.
Maybe not the most important thing happening in here.
So this is where the wire found.
So this was the wire found at each crime scene.
Should we send this in as evidence or do we no longer need
to?
I think probably send it in as evidence, right?
I feel a draft of air from somewhere below.
Any pointers, Zach?
All right, hold on.
I want to go in here first.
Wait, where's the music coming from?
So George was whipped with branches from the tree out back
by his mom, but he's supposedly still taking care of her in
her sickness.
No, I don't think she's sick.
I don't think she's around anymore, no?
Oh.
Otherwise, it almost feels like a Bates.
Where was the music coming from?
Hold on, I'm just looking around in other places.
Maybe in here?
Oh.
Oh, stuffed deer.
In the toilet.
So glad I could get a card of that.
Thank you.
I keep...
Okay.
The music keeps coming and going.
It must be downstairs then.
Stuffed here.
In the toilet.
That's where you put yours?
Push!
Alright.
All the wires.
Whoa!
Oh,
oh, the Emily.
Oh, Emily.
Where'd you get these photos from?
Zach, it looks like George really had a thing for Emily.
Did you not get that?
Did you not?
Did we not pick that up from all the times that everyone was
just like, he doesn't like me.
He likes you.
He likes you, Emily.
They explicitly said it.
This wall is covered with Emily's pictures.
I don't think Emily needs to see it.
I hope Emily's alive.
Clothes have been thrown on the bed.
The king's bed doesn't look comfortable.
What does the wall say?
I wonder if it's like Emily, Emily, Emily, Emily.
Emily, Emily, Emily.
I wonder if I can peek.
I wonder if... Does Kasen also have...
Is that the mom?
Observation bonus.
I don't think it's an alive person.
Whoever it is.
Yeah, paging Mr. Bates.
Exactly in Norman Bates' situation.
Oh my god.
What if they shaved Emily?
Oh no.
What?
The mother is always a bad experience.
after killing the sun.
Only is George's Oshie.
It's just his Eda door.
That's a freaky visual.
Yeah, he took care of her.
Yeah.
What?
Jack, look.
Wasn't a reverse peacemark.
It was the tree.
he did he said that interesting yeah i thought he said that
he was like red tree red tree red tree what does that mean
backwards what's that backwards ear to ear der ear der fk in
the coffee
wait wait are we smart is york stupid come to the theater
there the what did it say something curtain
oh come to the theater there the final curtain shall rise.
Red tree backwards is free super.
Hey, hey, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
Zach is always four steps ahead.
Why didn't Zach tell us?
Zach should have said something.
Hi, hello, I'm here.
Zach here.
Hi, York.
By the way, Kaysen?
You're just now figuring this out.
Maybe York was like too, you know...
Sure, we'll watch that after you.
Previously during the investigation.
Welcome to Greenvale.
Agent Francis York Morgan.
You're out of your mind.
The goddess won't smile for you anymore, George.
Which room is Emily in?
That wasn't a reverse peace mark.
Red tree.
Zach, I need you to pray with me.
Pray that things have not gone too far.
FS.
Oh, gosh, it's so old.
In the coffee.
Free soup.
I mean, 1956.
Raincoat killer.
Everybody, oh, people are dancing in the streets over
bodies.
Oh.
over there.
Red treat, thank you.
I mean, not red treat, thank you.
We're having mud, thank you.
Oh, thank you for the...
Oh, thank you.
Oh, shut up.
What?
I'm the Rocco killer!
Zach Morgan.
Come here.
Hello.
Oh, I can.
One.
Where do I need to go?
Do do do do do.
Oh no, don't sing it.
A bomb will go off.
Oh, this way.
Oh, oops.
Oh,
oh, oh, oh.
Wait, I have to get to the...
I have to get there before.
Wait.
How am I supposed to get there?
Oh!
I'm gonna get... I
gotta get there before 13, no?
Yeah, maybe I'm going the right way.
Yeah, I will follow the wall.
Oh, this is so cool.
Are they behind me?
I just hear them laughing.
This is so awesome.
Oh, someone's on me.
Oh my god, they're like, they're so fast and goofy looking.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Can I have a chainsaw?
What was it doing?
I don't want to run out of time!
I'm already at seven!
Yeah, the town has gone crazy.
The purple mist!
Oh, it closed off on me.
Eight!
We're getting there, we're getting there!
Oh gosh, okay.
500 yards left!
I am running.
This is walking.
This is running.
This wouldn't be so awesome if I wasn't so stressed about
it.
This would be...
I'd be like, yeah, yeah.
I'm running, I'm running!
We're almost there!
Oh, 11!
Oh, maybe I made it.
12.
Look at them.
Aren't they supposed to be killing each other?
What's happening?
Oh no, the music is playing again.
This is the quietest I've ever heard this song.
No way.
Whoa!
The gas!
the gas that they don't need masks she was the one laughing
shut up wait I remember seeing that guy
shut wait I remember seeing that guy and thinking like oh
one of these soldiers is not like the others I didn't say
anything but no way what it was K said oh no they're all
evil-fied no the whole town oh god daddy mommy and grandpa
everyone's acting strange it's okay what
Oh no, you little brats.
Ew, don't...
Oh my god, they just stabbed him with a pair of scissors.
You little...
Kusokaki!
Zach, the situation has gone way out of control.
I need to get inside the theater.
Okay.
Wait, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
What are you gonna make me do?
Oh my god.
Ah!
Wait, I'm stuck.
Let's try not to hurt them if we can.
Oh, okay.
They did nothing?
Probably when I'm jogging with my axe.
Holy cow!
Is this my suit?
Stink!
I've been sleeping in it.
Or no, it looks brand new.
Okay, we look good.
No, no, no.
Let's, um...
Let's get my first aid kits and stuff out.
Oh, but, uh...
Large first aid kit.
Yes.
Nice.
What?
How?
But... Wait, what?
But... I only took one.
Shouldn't I be able to stack them?
Such a narrow escape.
Can I only have one at a time, maybe?
Lame?
Okay.
Oh, my bait.
My country ham.
A high quality beef.
Okay.
I guess I haven't had to use anything.
I wonder if I should take this.
Oh, never mind.
What can I put away?
I don't know what would be better.
The shotgun or...
I'm like almost full.
on everything like we can maybe get some more magnum bullets
but i'm pretty i'm pretty full on stuff
we'll just get um oh wait and here we go
we can eat we can sleep oh let me sleep well honestly my
food and my sleep is like near full so
shotgun good for crowds magnum good for the boss pretty much
covered right right I feel like it um yeah I'm gonna heal I
will heal and then I'll grab another first aid kit
do not shave for cutscene hilarity oh wait I don't want to
put a word take item out
I'm just too good at the game.
Good luck with the final pause.
Thank you.
All right, let's go, baby.
This way?
Is...
Or is it this way?
Probably shouldn't try to get in here.
This way.
Open this way.
door there is no turning back you still want to enter very
well off you go mr.
York
the final wild ride starts now oh no Emily no no no no no no
no no no no George!
Oh right, George!
No, no.
He was a funny one.
He's a new bastard.
And he was so impressed.
So moved.
He wasn't very intelligent.
He was born in this town.
Are you saying that people born in small towns can't be
intelligent?
...to discover the red seeds.
A sign of small mindfulness represented in life.
I'm taking Emily.
Oh, but I can't allow that now.
Why is he talking like this all of a sudden?
Oh, well.
Oh, to me, in my care.
Remember, I told you to come, must did I?
What a jerk.
It looks like Evil Peter Griffin.
You chose your job over the woman that you love.
Oh!
Casey.
It's a killer, though.
It was a killer.
I mean, this guy too, but...
My fun with Emily ended just a moment ago.
It was a fantastic moment.
Like eating a full-course dinner that ends with the ultimate
dessert.
I fed her a fake story about my past And she took in every
word Cut out your nonsense I told you no more talk Yeah, you
tell him There you go Emily's too kind Emily's too nice
Where's the dog Really?
amazing history just like tiny ants that make giant ant
hills
you know i just had dessert and yet i'm already hungry again
no wonder why i keep failing at keeping a diet kason stop it
the next one will pierce you between your eyes
York.
Emily, I'm sorry I was asleep for a day and a half.
Everything will be fine now.
York?
Is that you?
Ew.
Oh, God.
York, I...
Emily, no.
Oh, no.
York.
Ah!
Emily!
No!
Oh!
York wouldn't lick me!
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I...
It's okay, Emily.
Hurry.
Come over here.
We need to get you to the hospital.
I don't think she can.
I can't.
I can't go to you.
Oh, God.
I've...
I've been soiled.
No, that's not true.
No, no, that's not true.
No, York, she literally has been soiled.
There's a tree in her!
She's literally been soiled!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
No.
Oh, didn't I tell you?
Getting these saplings to sprout requires a certain
technique.
Just shoot him, just shoot him.
Oh, sorry.
What do you think?
Artistic, isn't it?
It's like a surrealistic painting.
York, shoot me.
Let me die.
Please.
Oh, God.
What should I do?
You're asking me?
Uh...
Oh my god, this is like...
I'm sorry.
My darling.
Oh!
Let her go!
Remove that sattling from her body, Kasen.
Zander, it's too late.
Once it's like this, I can't do anything to stop it.
Please.
Darling.
Shoot me.
I'd rather die.
Yeah, how old is Kingston?
Let me die.
Maybe he really is immortal.
Because of the seeds.
If only he had shot him there.
Maybe he tries.
Oh my
god!
Oh my god!
At times we must purge things from this world they should
not exist
even if it means losing someone that you love oh yes I
couldn't do it however you can when the time comes and you
have to make that decision make the right one okay Zach oh
was I right oh my god we are zach i knew it zach
morgan francis zach
francis zach morgan
i saw you zach
That's why she was holding the case and...
That's...
Why does it have those?
Dante?
Virgil?
You Zach?
It's okay.
I'm here.
I'm with you.
The game tone, like, shifted entirely.
It's kind of crazy.
We can get through this together.
Who are you?
My name is York.
Me and you.
We'll always be together.
Okay, Zack?
I'm you.
And
give me your hand.
Oh, that's the scar on his eye.
What?
I
traded places with York.
The other me.
My other personality.
So funny.
Well, Zach, please, please shoot.
Now she's calling him Zach.
York, what should I do?
Tell me what to do, York.
Huh?
Uh.
Zach, you have to decide for yourself what you must do.
Aim at Kason.
Point the gun at own head.
Point gun at Emily.
Oh my God.
I think, is this the,
I want to try both of them But we're going to try Kason
first I don't deserve to live I want to try I want to try
all three of them I've always been more than human I'm a
messenger of the red tree A citizen from the red world
That's enough Kason
I knew this was going to be what was happening Gonna happen
because I Like the guy's immortal yeah I don't think it
would be so easy.
This is why everyone's weirded out when you insist on being
called Zach.
What a wacky twist.
Zach, you made the wrong choice.
But don't give up.
Think carefully.
Father's words will guide us.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
Now get.
Focus on reality, Zach.
Cool.
Okay.
Oh.
Give up.
No, no.
We'll start again.
Oh, it gives us another chance.
That's fine.
Okay, good.
Yeah, I wanted to see what would happen.
That's why I went with Kaysen first.
Should we try our own head and then, Emily?
die your beard or shave it kill me okay well yeah we'll go
for we'll go for our own head and then we'll go for York
what should I do tell me what to do York Zach you have to
decide for yourself what you must do poor Emily man she
looks so I'll be with you no matter what you decide don't
worry horrible horrible I can't
shoot you
Like father like son He's so comically like evil So I can't
take him seriously Even though he's disgusting
For so long No
We only had a short time together But I'm glad to have met
you goodbye so you do that and then she dies and everybody's
dead it's just so
all right now let's go for emily
this part's weird though this part's weird though you're
right you're right you're right zach you made the wrong
choice again i didn't want to say it but but don't give up
Think carefully.
It's so glitched again.
Didn't really, I didn't notice.
All right.
Now we can go for the right one.
Now get.
Focus on reality, Zach.
Start out.
Start out again.
I wonder if I can kit...
No, kit.
Wait.
Skip the cutscene.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Okay.
Fade to Y.
Yes.
ending do-overs pretty cool yeah i like it zach the illusion
of choice is better than forcing you to keep reloading from
the save file no i kind of i prefer it to be honest okay
zach you have to decide for yourself what you must do yes
i'll be with you no matter what you decide don't worry all
right point gun look at this guy he's like
there are some things in this world that must be extracted
no matter what
even if that means losing someone that you love are we
really gonna lose emily i'll be so sad
oh i can't i can't do it I can't kill Emily.
I'm sorry.
Stop.
Whoa!
Emily!
Ladies and gentlemen, and now the grand finale.
Emily,
what have you done?
Zach, I wasn't used as soil at all.
Most beautiful person I've ever seen.
Thank you, Zach.
I want to.
No, she's going to become a goddess of the forest.
Or maybe they'll save her.
No, I don't think so.
Oh, she's going to join them.
No!
You aren't supposed to go over there.
That's not the way.
Come back, Emily.
Thomas thinks he's part of the team.
Him and Carol, honestly, they both sucked.
I understand.
Stinking siblings.
I'm a little jealous.
Aww.
Hey, stand up.
It's up to you now.
Emily, I finally got to meet you face to face.
But you had to go with York, didn't you?
He always gets the girl.
You see that too, right?
York?
Oh my god, that way she's with York!
And ended up pulling me back out of that room.
i'm sure he'll make you very happy his delusions ntr by the
alter ego
it's always my belief that everyone was calling him zach he
was just that much of an unreliable narrator he just heard
york every time yeah i think so too
why did you bring zach back who how did you get out of the
red room
Oh my god.
He's turned into the blueberry kid from...
From Willy Wonka.
Oh my god!
No wonder he could run...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Showing off?
What is...
Wait.
What's going on?
Oh, now we're fighting.
It's show time.
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh my god, the arms.
What am I supposed to shoot at?
Oh, I'm just supposed to shoot at him!
Oh.
Uh, where?
Oh!
You fool!
Ouch!
Is I supposed to have made that?
Oops.
What was that, Zach?
Eek!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, what?
You should have just stayed in there.
I see now.
Okay, I pressed B to win,
but...
He's so loud.
Oh my gosh.
Hey?
You should have just stayed in there.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I panicked.
Don't panic.
Dang it.
Oh, come on!
I need to reload.
No.
Okay, I think I can get, like, one more shot in.
Oh!
Why?
B!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I am gonna heal though, just in case.
The fall is...
This guy is like comically stupid looking and like...
He's just comically everything.
So it's hard to take him seriously.
He is so goofy.
Oh, uh...
Oh.
I can't...
I always have to look down to make sure I'm pressing the
right thing.
Oh, uh, uh, okay.
We almost had him.
You haven't shown me your real strength?
Oh, shoot.
Uh, X.
Oh, ah!
Dang it!
You fool.
Oh, it's so close.
Oh, dang it.
I think I can get him here.
If my pointer...
Oh shoot, that sucks.
YA!
Yeah, it didn't do much though to me.
There we go.
Alright, phase two then?
Hopefully that reloaded.
Hopefully that worked.
Oh!
The red room or the white room?
What do you want me to go?
Humans are so foolish.
He's there.
Yeah, is that why he's there too?
There's nothing to tell.
With one whiff of that gas I made for you.
From the seeds, they happily kill each other.
One thing I noticed was the title of the episode that we
played as the Red Killer was his dad.
Was York's dad.
It was the name.
So I'm like...
I think I do be yapping there.
And I really don't like having to exercise.
Oh.
I know it's Zach, but I'm gonna keep calling him.
I'm gonna keep calling him York.
I'm used to it.
Oh, my God.
What is happening?
Oh,
my God.
I thought we were about to have to run.
I thought we were about to have to do that.
Ourselves.
I'm running.
Oh.
My god.
Oh my god.
Am I supposed to shoot?
I can't shoot.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Why?
Thanks.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, this is evil.
This is evil.
One.
Wait.
I'm gonna have to use my right hand.
Oh, what?
Actually!
Two!
Am I supposed to shoot him at all?
I can't tell.
No, no.
My axe!
Okay.
I have my gun, but I cannot turn around and shoot him or
anything.
So...
Oh, God.
My hand is hurting.
My hand is hurting so bad.
Wee, wee, wee, wee.
Oh.
Oh, no, I did the wrong one.
Oh, no, please.
Three?
Ugh.
Mr. Stewart, save me!
Wee, wee, wee!
Oh, my gosh.
Uh, uh, uh, why hex?
Okay.
Ah!
No, no, no, dang it!
Oh, that was dirty.
That was dirty.
Wait, can I heal?
Okay, good, I can.
Let me go into my mind palace for two seconds.
Yeah.
Wombo comboed for real.
Cheap shot.
Okay.
Oh, God.
My hand hurts so bad.
Wait, I...
My hand hurts so...
My arm...
This is so much!
Oh, God!
Oh, thank God.
Oh.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Oh.
This is a cool...
This is where we're going to fight him, right?
Yeah, he'll be- he'll come crawling back up.
I'd say this is harder than the MGS-1 torture scene, I would
say so.
Emily, I will avenge your death.
Just a moment longer.
I'll buy you a new dress to make up for all the pain I've
caused you.
The dress you wore when you came to my hotel room didn't
seem to fit you right.
Why?
Oh!
All right.
Is it time to avenge her death?
Oh,
it's just...
Wait, he's like just giant Kason.
Not the
Willy Patch!
Attack on Zack!
I've been meaning to tell you this.
You're one crazy guy.
What?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, he's holding his little figurine.
Where do I shoot at?
Whoa!
Okay, this is like an actual boss fight.
Maybe I shoot at the figurine.
Yeah, it looks like it.
Nice.
Can I shoot it again?
Dang it, I missed you.
Maybe.
This figure, why is this figure like...
Yeah, it's like a voodoo doll.
Oh.
What's happening?
Like, something sounds like...
Maybe he's just walking.
I think he's just walking, actually.
Oh, gosh.
I'm trying to, like, take the shot.
When I...
Even when I...
Ah, no, I had it!
Music.
Come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
Stop it.
Where's my...
I can't see.
Ah!
Oh!
Okay, good.
That was a close one.
And...
At least it has a pretty big hit bomb, so I'll give it, I'll
grant it that.
Gosh.
No!
There we go.
Oh, let's reload.
Oh.
Oh shoot.
This game is...
It was so serious for like 10 minutes and then it became
goofiness.
Oh, that was close.
It's like when I ride and fall out and fought all the rays.
That's exactly how this feels.
Oh my gosh.
If my aim wasn't such dukey though.
Ah.
Actually this is fine.
You have died.
Why
are you laughing like that?
Is that it?
I need to reload.
I saw a chat right in the boss name spot for a brief moment.
Thought he was called Hawk Tooler.
Wait, uh, hello?
Why'd you get rid of it?
Yeah?
What are we doing now?
walk.
Okay, we're still going?
Maybe I...
Okay, maybe it's not attack.
Is he still holding it?
And it's just like, got missing?
Maybe not.
I sure hope that I don't have to beat him by the time of the
clock.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, thank you.
Who sent that?
So now I have to, yeah, I have to, like, interact with it.
It's not, like, a shoot it.
Okay, here we go.
I'm up.
Oh, okay.
Get up on the Hydra's back!
Oh, I'm also wondering that...
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, I found him!
Oh!
I found him!
Move your head, please!
He's in your pocket!
Can I get to the...
Please!
Stop!
Uh, A, X, A!
Oh, I did Y.
Dang it.
That was so close.
I just have to get the doll in his pocket.
Wait.
no way is he holding it again oh he revived no no no no how
much is he gonna revive okay i stopped it maybe i stopped it
for now oh my god no no no gosh no please
with your iframes
he has like this tiniest sliver of health left can you see
It is crazy.
There we go.
I think now he'll put it away?
Maybe.
Yes, he puts it away now.
Two drunk nerds fighting in slow motion, but one is Goliath
for some reason.
I think he threatened to put Zack in a jaw.
All right.
It's in your pocket.
I bet.
What do you think I am?
Five?
Got your nose!
I'm up.
Where is he?
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh!
I got it!
How'd we get off of him?
Whoa.
Oh, he's so sick.
Phase three?
It's because you don't understand humans.
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
The turnaround!
Yes!
He's too cool!
Oh my god!
He was about to kill her!
Before the purple mist, there's a surprising number of alive
people down here, I think.
That would have been a perfect la-la moment.
So true.
Emily, York tries not to show it, but he's pretty shy.
Don't wait for him to propose.
Just ask him to marry you.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, Emily.
Hmm?
Oh, the doll.
Destroy it, destroy it.
Smash it to bits.
Yeah.
This
is a heavy chapter.
Let's go Minto, you did it.
Aw, man.
I still got pan.
I just realized the entire police force is dead.
Wait, you're right.
You're so right.
Zachview.
Previously during the investigation, York, the other me.
My other personality.
There are some things in this world that must be extracted.
No matter what.
York, I'm sorry.
I...
Let me beg.
Red tree!
Poor Emily.
York and Zach.
The paperwork for this case is going to be a mess, so true.
You two really are best friends.
I'm a little jealous.
I'm sure he'll make you very happy Didn't haven't we known
her for a week?
What do you mean just to Just propose to him?
What do we mean by that?
Emily did end up in the picture
Mr. Stewart Wait, he took off the gas now Are you leaving
today?
Maybe Zach That story I told you the other day Did you
believe any of it?
The fact of the matter is that I couldn't save Emily.
So it really doesn't matter whether I believed you or not.
I'm very sorry about her.
Yeah, I think it was false.
I think it was...
There's something mysterious about that, people.
Dad, no?
There's a calming beauty to it.
There's something, I don't know.
And yet it exudes sadness.
Harry, I have a few questions for you.
What about what, Zach?
Your last name isn't really Stuart, is it?
Yeah, that is correct.
It's really Woodman.
Harry Wood, who was my son.
What?
You were there in the White Room when I was there.
Yeah.
Why?
The same reason as your father.
The
mental illness.
But I still loved her.
I wanted to save George, too, if I could.
So says Mr. Woodman.
Everything was my fault.
Courage to make the right decision.
Emily and the other girls would not have died.
Even he's saying that.
Is he feeding her delusions or is this real?
I mean, I guess it's real because, like...
Oh, the soundtrack is crazy.
I mean, if you can have crazy demon Kaysen, I think York can
be a real guy, right?
Emily.
twin peaks music actually that one song and twin peaks oh
hey michael mind stopping the car for a moment very well mr
francis zach morgan why does this sound like a prequel to
fire watch i i don't know what you're thinking laura's theme
yeah yeah yeah oh the
children i heard you're leaving oh willy willy are you okay
are you a demon dog
willy's okay by the way these kids stabbed me in the back
literally uh-huh that's right with a knife i mean scissors
sorry it's a shame about emily and the other girls too now
our population is five we're a town of five how are isaac
and isaiah but i guess emily if you think about it emily
fell in love with york they still don't think she didn't
fall in love with zach give
it to him yourself he's right next to you
Red rum, red rum, the children are...
Oh, okay.
I understand.
We'll do it for you.
The children are seeing ghosts?
The children are seeing dead people!
Um, Emily kind of told us to give this to you.
Emily said it's a present for Zach.
Thank you.
Where did you get this?
Emily asked us to give it to you.
See, she's over there.
There's another Zach there too.
You're twins, just like us.
Emily couldn't give it to you herself.
She said she's too embarrassed.
So, she asked us to hand it to you.
Emily really
likes that guy, York.
The guy you see standing next to her.
It looks like his harem.
Anyways, you two.
Be nice to the girls, okay?
Well, yeah, woman eyes are over here.
Girls are boring.
We like ghosts.
Girls are boring!
I'll show you boring, you little brats.
What are you talking about?
Thomas is part of the harem.
Just full of energy.
They can see spirits, including Anna's mom, which is why
she's so distraught seeing her daughter's spirit during the
investigation.
I figured out why George carried Anna's body all the way
into the woods.
It was for them.
he wanted Isaac and Isaiah to find her what a weirdo what if
the ghosts were also girls oh hello he's like you're taking
a really long time if you are finished no way no way life is
beautiful yeah you can go home I'm gonna take a look around
how are we gonna get back very well then I'm sure Mr.
Stewart will approve of that.
Ah, thank you, Michael.
Oh, Michael.
His name is Michael.
Sorry, I doubted you, Michael.
Sorry I thought you were the killer.
Michael did one thing.
I sussed him out so hard.
I was like, Michael, Michael.
What the?
Life is so beautiful, my friends.
Life is so beautiful.
The game is absolute cinema, ironically and unironically.
I feel, honestly though, all my friends are dead.
I feel really sad.
I was like, oh, I can't go visit George.
I can't go visit Thomas.
I can't go visit Emily.
Everybody's dead.
I'm pretty sad right now.
Is this just new game plus then?
Do I just stay here until I feel like leaving?
Time to visit Polly.
Let's go do a little fishing.
Yeah, we can fish and then I'll call it quits.
Actually, hold on.
I think I'm meeting with the girls in 30 minutes.
Yes.
So...
Emily's dead, but we can go fishing!
Wait.
Can I not talk to...
I'm Zach.
So we don't talk to Zach anymore.
Wait, also, there's something over here.
Oh, talk?
You're...
Can you hear me?
I'm a little jealous.
I'm all alone on this side now.
But don't worry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I've had it easy for so long having you with me.
I need to get used to being on my own.
Oh, that car literally just dropped from the sky.
Did you guys see that?
That's so sad!
Can I have a recap?
It's been a great journey.
No, it's not that...
No, don't say you're not smart.
Stop.
It's quite a artistic ending, right?
But I think it's both paranormal and like...
and not you know it's like a lot definitely happened i'm
trying to i'm struggling to think of how to recap this to be
honest um
there was
a killer in the 50s because of the gas that was pushed into
the town as for some reason i guess they were i guess i
guess uh kason's just you know i mean not just i guess um we
know he's a crazy guy he's a crazy demon from the red world
and he made this gas out of the red seeds and it turns
people evil crazy wanting for blood and and uh oh sorry Eyes
on the road, everybody.
This is your sign.
Oh, let's go this way.
And, um...
Yeah, check the...
Check the wiki, maybe.
The wiki might be a little more comprehensive than I am.
Uh, I'm just trying to...
I'm trying to consolidate my thoughts as well, I suppose.
Where it's like...
Oh.
One more thing, York.
Thank you.
going well with emily you've always been horrible with women
i gave you tons of advice during your last relationship and
you ignored all of it i'm sure emily will take the lead just
don't fight her let her steer you in the right direction
the relationship advice but yeah because of that the seeds
um makes people go crazy Oh, we're going back to the hotel,
I just realized.
I thought maybe we were.
Let's go talk to Polly.
Never got a chance to tell you this here.
One crazy maid.
Um, but we're, we're Zach and we have trauma because of
stinking Kaysen.
And also maybe our dad was a bit of a jerk.
I don't know, actually.
That part's questionable.
We split into two personalities, but one is probably
actually real or something.
Moral of the story, don't be a cute city girl who moves to
the countryside.
Do not the blue tree, blueberry, alien always aim for the
Funko Pop.
Why is that a quick?
Why is that a- York, tonight I'm going to sleep like a baby.
Why was that a quick QTE?
week.
Literally like a one week.
Virgil, thank you!
Zach, it's over.
All finished.
It's time for you to leave town.
Are you ready to go?
And this is goodbye, Zach.
No!
Thank you for everything.
Yorick, no!
And sleep tight.
Thank you guys for the super chance.
Thank you, thank you.
Screw you, Kaysen.
Polly, what's that picture?
Oh, that.
We took it when the clock tower was built.
Wait, Kaysen said he always stayed at this place?
That's right.
That's me in the middle.
I was pretty popular back then.
50 years ago!
Men were always around me.
Yeah, look at him.
He's actually immortal.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
Just sign here, please.
Mr. Morgan Mr. Morgan Oh, I'm sorry, Polly.
I was just thinking of a friend, someone who was with me for
a long, long time.
He must have been a really good friend then.
Otherwise, why else would you remember him at a time like
this?
Indeed.
We used to fight, but he really was a good person.
He's gone now, though.
Gone away to a place where we can't.
meet again I'm sorry to hear that but if he's a friend of
yours I'm sure he's getting on just fine thank you Polly you
know what I think so too oh
now we have to walk to the airport I guess no one's picking
us up oh yeah this is where we first met everybody they're
all Oh my gosh.
York smoked but...
Oh.
Zach doesn't.
What the heck?
Everything is so loud.
Willie or... Poor Willie!
La la la la la la la.
He's just gonna walk home, I guess, yeah.
But the ending song is so emo-y.
Let's go, Swery!
Yeah!
I have a feeling there might be a post-credit scene, so...
Yeah, Swery!
Wait, I am, like, so honest.
ironically love this game.
Forrest Kaysen is a bit of a digital actor who plays
different roles in various sweary games, like Dark Dreams
Don't Die, or Spy Fiction.
Wait, that's awesome!
Also, your name Ankylosaurus.
Let's go.
I hope you enjoyed my favorite game of all time!
I look forward to your next digital adventure at the PNW.
But yeah, I guess we have to do Alan Wake 2 now, huh?
Or eventually.
Maybe a return to Brightfall.
This game is so silly goofy, but I always thought the reveal
with Zack was genuinely so awesome.
If you want more Swery Madness, I recommend D4 over D P2.
Sadly, cancel.
But what we got is P.
I'm still thinking about Deadly Premonition 2.
What a game.
Maybe life really is beautiful.
Where was all of this music?
Great job on being Deadly Premonition 2!
Hi, Katsu!
Thank you!
I remember watching your playthrough in my hotel at Oshi
Epling.
Glad to see you completed.
Thank you!
Oh, Essie!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Hello!
She prayed!
Hi, Essie!
Hi, I'm Minto.
It's nice to meet you.
I saw you were collabing with Kiwawa earlier for the...
For the World Cup!
I hope the team!
Whoever won!
I think Kiwawa was rooting for Spain though, right?
I think so.
Oh, Dorgo, thank you!
Wait, wait, oh, two out of two.
Wait, wait, where's the one?
Where's the one?
Yeah, Spain won!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow, thank you guys for all this overcharge.
I can't read everything.
Oh, recap, there was a girl named Violet who broke down.
Because she didn't understand humans, question mark.
He brought his voodoo Funko Pop with him.
The funny thing is, I don't think I saw him with that
literally any other time.
Did he have his little Funko Pop with him before?
Or am I crazy?
Am I crazy?
He always had the plant, yes he did.
That's why I thought it was him from the beginning, but I
was like, there's no way.
There's no way.
It's so obvious.
I think he occasionally had it.
This song has a vocal version?
I tried
to hide my sadness I tried to hide my sadness No, thank you
Thank you so much for the pink
Nobody can tell me a horizon Appeared after the surrender
I tried to vanish my scar.
Wait, wait, wait.
In the darkness with the genuine dear.
What I love about dreadly premonition is it's unrepentant.
about doing whatever it wants.
It could be heartfelt, stupid, disgusting, horrifying,
ingenious, all with a span of 15 minutes.
Truly.
Oh.
What?
I love this though.
So good.
The AP2 is a bad game, but it's still fun to hang out with
York one last time.
My brain is melted.
This game was freaking wild, Rye, but a blast.
Thank you for playing it.
Thank you for watching it.
Yeah, I've seen footage of Deadly Premonition 2, and it
just, like, is...
So laggy.
Like, the...
frame rate is crazy that was amazing i feel like we learned
something i don't know what but
they're just they're just so in rabu staring in each other's
eyes
epilogue oh my goodness is it alternative unused thomas
carol vocal tracking called find called pillow stains i
believe that's the same name as the one in the game but the
song is completely different.
It's very pretty.
Oh, thank you.
Smooching as everyone stands there staring at them.
So goofy.
Glad you like the game, Minto.
Be sure to check out White Owls and the games.
They're all weird and low budget.
At least one.
And at least one is great.
The missing not deadly premonition two.
You back I noticed an actual location reference to Twin
Peaks!
It's never used for this game's plot, but it's still cool to
see it as he drove by.
No way!
That's so cool!
I think there's dialogue on the menu.
Wait, what?
Wait, they're special, but it won't let- Oh, there it is.
What's this?
Are these like references?
Wait, that's so fun!
Wait, what's happening?
What?
There's also all that other stuff.
Wait, why can't I see the photos?
Select.
Oh, here we go.
He's sand!
Wait, that looks just like the turkey sandwich!
And the hot dogs!
Whoa, that looks great.
Oh, I'm getting hungry.
Oh, those look like crispy cream.
Happy!
What else is there?
Trading call.
Question mark, question mark, question mark.
It won't let me go, interesting.
And also this.
JB.
Wait, it had like numbers and stuff.
I'm trying to read the note.
But I, it's so fast.
Oh, a jukebox!
Wait, television.
Whoa, neat.
Please stop the car.
Oh, that's where it's
like...
Unrepeat!
Every day!
Comic relief.
This song is literally called Comic Relief.
This song is called Comic Relief.
much fun guys i do want to have a little bit of dinner
before i meet with the girls so i will do that um we have
some last minute planning to do so oh this is so fun thank
you guys so much for deadly premonition i'm gonna miss this
game so much oh i'm gonna miss this game so much
La la la la la La
la la Make me thank you Mmm I want a hot dog with a toasted
bun So good Yes my outfit!
My new outfit!
Tomorrow!
Please!
Please come see!
Ooh Wait, we're doing a picture right?
Uh, there here New outfit!
New outfit!
Tomorrow!
4 p.m.
PS3 7 p.m.
p.m.
EST, 11 p.m.
GMT, 8 a.m.
JST, and I will then afterwards be doing a little bit of a
karaoke after the debut.
So tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow.
Oh, my schedule for the week.
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
Da-da-da-da.
This song is driving me insane.
New album tomorrow, post-debue karaoke.
Bloons on Tuesday.
How World collab with Slopey Sisters, Atari, Enemy
Nightmare.
Wednesday, I'll do Home Safety Hotline.
I just felt like, I don't know, I want to do something
spooky.
Friday, Legends and New, and I'll be at Offa Kai as well
this weekend.
So, hopefully, I'll see you there.
Offa Kai Exhipo!
And Densatsu 3D, first 3D live!
We have streaming tickets.
They're still available.
If you want to watch, so.
stuff happening this week, but definitely come and check out
the Overday View tomorrow!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'll be...
Oh, wait, the 22nd.
Oh, wait.
I'll be back the 29th.
Thank you.
I'll change it before I post it.
I didn't even...
Whoopsie.
I'll be back the 29th.
I've taken a few days to hang out with some friends in the
area.
My bad!
I'm actually changing it right now.
29!
I didn't even notice.
Okay!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you!
LegendsAnew.com, the streaming tickets.
The show itself is sold out, but streaming tickets are at
LegendsAnew.com.
If you're going to, if you're going to, off-kai, maybe
gather some friends for a watch party or something.
Or some friends at your house, whatever, whatever.
Or just chill.
Enjoy the show by yourself.
Discord call, whichever you want to do.
Yeah.
Thank you everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Safe travels and happy friend time boss.
Thank you!
Wait, nesting glitch case.
Is your YouTube being strange?
Thank you, everyone!
Thank you, thank you!
He's in jail.
No!
Wait, before we go, I want to hear one more thing.
What would be...
Oh.
Is it this one?
No.
York and Zack.
Ah.
Big red casein.
Forest casein.
Wait, I'm trying to find a la-la.
Here we go.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Oh, it's a meato.
Bye-bye.
It's the la-la's.
Where's the lollas?